Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, episode number 8, Prologue. Take it away, Jason. So I got some good news and I got some bad news. That's the way they always come in pairs. Yeah, it's true. It's a dichotomy.
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 8 期，序幕。Jason，开始吧。我有个好消息，也有个坏消息。消息总是成对出现的。没错，这是一种二分法。
The good news is I got a smartphone. Finally? It's the 21st century. Yeah, that's right. I went through this issue where it's like, oh, I want an iPhone. And it's like, oh, wait for the next iPhone. And then, oh, wait for the next iPhone. And, you know, it's just perpetual paralysis. But I got to the point where, you know,
好消息是我买了部智能手机。终于买了？现在都 21 世纪了。是啊，没错。我之前一直纠结，心想，哦，我想买 iPhone。然后又想，再等等下一代 iPhone 吧。接着又想，再等等下一代。你知道，这简直是永无止境的纠结。但我终于下定决心，你知道，
with moving and needing a new number and everything, I felt like it was time to abandon my feature phone and go smartphone. And I'm loving it. I think it's awesome. I love, I'm totally geeking out with it. The other day we had to walk to the post office and we go there constantly. But I used Google Maps and it kind of like gave you walking directions and you could see yourself in your phone.
随着搬家、需要新号码等等原因，我觉得是时候放弃我的功能机，换成智能手机了。我非常喜欢它。我觉得它太棒了。我完全沉迷其中。前几天我们得步行去邮局，我们经常去那里。但我用了谷歌地图，它能提供步行导航，你还能在手机上看到自己的位置。
Yeah. See like a top-down view like you're playing Pac-Man or something. This is the honeymoon period. Yeah, that's right. You're an expert on the smartphone, right? No, I'm not an expert. But, yeah, I remember first getting one and you're like, and you get all these apps for it and all this stuff. And then eventually it kind of lulls out, and you get bored of it, and then you kind of settle into a good routine where you're not overusing it.
是啊。就像玩《吃豆人》那样，能看到俯视图。这是蜜月期。没错。你是智能手机专家，对吧？不，我不是专家。但是，我记得刚买的时候，你会下载各种应用，折腾各种东西。最后你会慢慢冷静下来，感到厌倦，然后进入一种良好的日常使用状态，不会过度使用它。
But it sounds like probably maybe too nerdy or overly dramatic, but I feel like it changes how I do things. Like I look up stuff today. I was at the mall with my brother and my wife and my brother, uh, asked, said, what is this? Or something? Some shirt had some phrase on it. We didn't know.
但这听起来可能有点书呆子气或者太戏剧化了，但我感觉它改变了我的做事方式。比如今天我查了一些东西。我和我兄弟还有我妻子在商场，我兄弟问，这是什么？或者类似的话。某件衬衫上印着一句话。我们不知道是什么意思。
So I just looked it up. I'm like, not going to wait. I would have only forgotten. Now I know what it means. It's useless, but one cool thing we did, I was,
所以我直接查了一下。我想，我可不想等。不然我肯定会忘掉。现在我知道它是什么意思了。虽然没什么用，但我们做了一件很酷的事，我当时，
we were at sports authority and, we, uh, we're looking at sport watches cause we've been doing a lot of running lately, my wife and I. And so there was this one sports watch, and I took a picture of it with Google Goggles and found it was cheaper at Kmart. Yeah. Be careful of doing that. So I do this all the time.
我们在 Sports Authority，我们在看运动手表，因为我和我妻子最近一直在跑步。当时有款运动手表，我用 Google Goggles 拍了张照，发现 Kmart 卖得更便宜。是啊。做这种事要小心。我经常这么做。
Amazon has a barcode scanning app app and it'll tell you the price on amazon or anywhere else and i got amazon prime so i get free shipping always in two days that's pretty good right so yeah if you're that's one thing sorry to interject but if you're a high school or a college student and you have an edu email address you can get amazon prime for free so definitely yeah you should do that also i think uh caregivers like stay-at-home moms and something i don't know there's a bunch. Also, I think caregivers, like stay-at-home moms and something. I don't know. There's a bunch of people. I don't know how many stay-at-home moms we have listening to our podcast.
亚马逊有个条形码扫描应用，它会告诉你亚马逊或其他地方的价格。我有亚马逊 Prime 会员，所以总是能享受两天免费送达，这很不错，对吧？所以，如果你是高中生或大学生，有 edu 邮箱地址，你可以免费获得亚马逊 Prime 会员，一定要去申请。另外，我觉得护理人员，比如全职妈妈之类的，我不知道，有很多这类人。我不知道有多少全职妈妈在听我们的播客。
I don't know. Hundreds. Hundreds. Okay. Thousands. But yeah, so you go to the store and you're looking at something on Amazon. So that's great because you're saving money, right? Like I'm just going to order it on Amazon or even right from my phone and get it in two days and that part's not bad that's good okay the bad part is
我不知道。几百个吧。几百个。好吧。几千个。但总之，你去商店时，会在亚马逊上查看商品。这很好，因为你省钱了，对吧？就像我直接在亚马逊上订购，或者直接用手机下单，两天就能收到，这部分不错，挺好的。好吧，坏处是
sometimes you want to buy it or you need to buy it because you need it kind of right then for something but you see the reviews and if you look at the reviews for like you know half to three quarters of stuff in the store like going through target or walmart or kmart or whatever or like that watch right you scan it and you look at the reviews online and you'll find out it's terrible. And then you won't buy it. And in the end, it wouldn't have, well, maybe a watch is a bad example, but like a t-shirt and it's like, oh, this t-shirt, you know, starts to lose threads really fast. It's like, you wouldn't normally care.
有时候你想买或者需要买，是因为你当时急需某样东西，但你看到了评论。如果你去查看商店里一半到四分之三商品的评论，比如逛 Target、Walmart 或 Kmart 之类的，或者像那块手表，你扫描一下，查看在线评论，就会发现它很烂。然后你就不会买了。最后，其实，好吧，手表可能不是个好例子，但比如一件 T 恤，上面写着，哦，这件 T 恤很快就会脱线。通常你根本不会在意。
But now because you see the reviews are two stars on Amazon, you don't buy it. Oh, I see what you're saying i think that on the the contra is the opposite is also true though i noticed that like a lot of mom and pop restaurants that yes same thing you know they always say that like the like the ugliest looking mom and pop restaurants have the best food but it's like at the same time it's like you know it's like you never know what you're gonna get and you can't really sue them for millions if it's just a mom pop restaurant so they have less on the line than like a like you know it's like you never know what you're gonna get and you can't really sue them for millions if it's just a mom-pop restaurant so they have less on the line than like a mcdonald's or something which has to cook your food right you know um so but but yelp
但现在因为你看到亚马逊上的评论只有两星，你就不买了。哦，我明白你的意思了。但我认为反过来也是成立的。我注意到很多家庭小餐馆，是的，也是一样。你知道，人们常说那些看起来最破旧的家庭小餐馆食物最好吃，但同时，你永远不知道你会得到什么，而且如果只是家小餐馆，你也没法起诉他们索赔数百万美元，所以他们承担的风险比麦当劳之类的连锁店要小，后者必须保证食物质量，对吧？你知道，嗯，所以，但是 Yelp
really helps there are other apps you know they if you find a place that's rated really well or a place that's rated really poorly it could really influence your judgment well but at least the same analysis paralysis because you'll be somewhere and there'll be no good reviewed restaurants around. So you won't. It's like, where do I go? There's nothing good. So you'll like drive really far to go somewhere that's good, even though it's really not that. I don't know.
真的很有帮助。还有其他应用，你知道，如果你找到一家评价很高或很差的餐馆，这真的会影响你的判断。嗯，但至少会有同样的分析瘫痪，因为你身处某地，周围却没有评价好的餐馆。所以你不会去。就像，我该去哪儿？没啥好吃的。所以你会开车跑很远去吃一家好的，尽管其实也没那么好。我不知道。
It's just about being unique because people on Yelp, for instance, will pan a McDonald's or a Quiznos because it's a chain restaurant and they prefer independent restaurants over chain restaurants on average. That's my opinion. I have no idea if that's true. Yeah, definitely. I think that there is like – there are – what's the word? Biases. Yeah, exactly. There is an inherent bias to the people on Yelp and on these sites,
这只是因为人们的独特性，比如 Yelp 上的用户会抨击麦当劳或 Quiznos，因为那是连锁餐厅，而他们平均来说更喜欢独立餐厅。这是我的观点。我不知道这是否属实。是的，绝对。我认为存在某种——有什么词来着？偏见。是的，没错。Yelp 和这些网站上的用户存在固有的偏见，
especially people that review them, not so much patrons. But I feel like as the barrier of entry to reviewing things goes down like as like for example you have your smartphone and it has a gps so it knows so it could even just be smart enough to know you went in a restaurant and came out you know and know that you were there for an hour and just say hey why don't you write a blur about this restaurant and uh as it becomes that easy i think you'll get a more diverse population doing reviews but as it is now yeah a lot of kind of hipster people who you know are really against the man and and chain anything a lot of those people are the ones doing the reviews yeah i actually saw so this is really interesting thing too and we didn't have this in our news but it is is interesting so i'll talk about it now where uh they did a study saying people are really
尤其是那些写评论的人，而不是顾客。但我感觉随着评论门槛的降低，比如你有了智能手机，它有 GPS，所以它甚至可以聪明到知道你进了一家餐馆又出来了，知道你在那儿待了一个小时，然后说，嘿，你为什么不写点关于这家餐馆的评论呢？随着它变得如此简单，我认为会有更多样化的人群参与评论。但就目前而言，是的，很多那种愤世嫉俗、反对大企业和连锁店的人才是写评论的主力。是的，我其实看到了——这真是一件很有趣的事，我们新闻里没提，但确实很有趣，所以我现在说说——他们做了一项研究，说人们真的
well i guess it's kind of like people are really bad at predicting what they're going to want in the future so uh they were taking for netflix if you ask people like you can build a queue in netflix and these are the movies i'm going to watch in the future and you'll put like all these highbrow movies on like artistic independent films but then if it actually comes time to watch a movie you watch like stupid silly movies that you just want to watch to have a laugh and aren't serious and don't make you think because but in the future you think you're going to be like a smarter person you're going to read these fancy books and watch these you know really intelligent movies but you don't end up actually doing that and it's the same thing i think happens on yelp where people want this idea of eating these nice restaurants all the time
嗯，我想这就像是人们在预测自己未来想要什么方面真的很差。所以，对于 Netflix，如果你问人们，你可以建立一个 Netflix 队列，这些是我未来要看的电影，你会放上所有那些高雅的电影，比如艺术独立电影。但当真正到了看电影的时候，你会看那些愚蠢、傻气的电影，你只是想笑一笑，不需要动脑子。因为在未来，你认为自己会成为一个更聪明的人，你会读那些高深的读物，看那些真正有内涵的电影，但你最终并没有那样做。我认为 Yelp 上也发生了同样的事情，人们想要那种一直去高档餐厅吃饭的想法，
but in reality most people just end up going to mcdonald's and quiznos and subway because you just want something you know what you're going to get yeah because if you think about it planning in general like planning ahead and thinking about the future is is kind of hard i mean that's like that requires like a lot of computation that gets into the like the area of the brain that does like really hard complex stuff and so probably when you're in that mode you're more apt to like look at something intellectual but then the spur of the moment like oh i want to watch a comedy kicks in you know like an interrupt or interrupt or something. And so, yeah, you're just not accounting for that. So welcome to the world of smartphones. That is good news.
但实际上，大多数人最终还是去了麦当劳、Quiznos 和赛百味，因为你只想吃点你知道是什么味道的东西。是的，因为如果你仔细想想，规划本身，即提前规划和思考未来，是有点困难的。这意味着这需要大量的计算，会调用大脑中处理复杂事务的区域。所以当你处于那种模式时，你更倾向于看一些有内涵的东西，但当突发奇想时，比如“哦，我想看部喜剧”，那种冲动就会接管大脑。所以，是的，你只是没有考虑到这一点。所以欢迎来到智能手机的世界。这是个好消息。
Maybe now you'll be able to send the emails a little quicker and be pestered all the time with interruptions. Yeah, definitely. So you said you had some bad news too? It's been pretty awesome. Yeah, so the bad news. Am I going to cry? I need to get tissues. They installed a bike rack in our complex, which I thought was great.
也许现在你能更快地发送电子邮件，并一直被各种干扰所困扰。是的，绝对。所以你说你还有坏消息？这真的很棒。是的，坏消息。我会哭吗？我需要拿纸巾。他们在我们小区安装了一个自行车架，我觉得这很好。
That's not bad news. Yeah, I left my bike there. And after two days of leaving my bike there, it was stolen. Someone had cut the... Yeah, the bike rack was inside of our garage, which requires like a clicker to go in and out of. So our hypothesis is that somebody just kind of snuck in behind a car. And then, you know, once you're inside, you can easily get out. So they just snuck in and took our bike.
那不是坏消息。是的，我把自行车停在那儿了。停了两天后，它被偷了。有人剪断了……是的，自行车架在我们的车库里，进出需要遥控器。所以我们的假设是有人跟着一辆车溜了进来。然后，你知道，一旦你进去了，就能很容易地出来。所以他们溜进来偷走了我们的车。
You know, I bought one of those cheap chains. It's just like several steel, you know, threads that are kind of woven together. And so they just cut through that. Did you see it? Did it get picked or did they just cut it? No, they cut it. Yeah, they cut through it. So, because I had like, it was a frayed end, you know, they left the chain there.
你知道，我买的是那种便宜的链条锁。就是几根钢丝编在一起的那种。他们直接剪断了。你看到了吗？是被撬开的还是直接剪断的？不，是剪断的。是的，他们剪断了。因为锁头边缘磨损了，你知道，他们把链条留在那儿了。
Well, that was nice of them. Yeah. So, you know, it really sucks, but this is actually brings up a really interesting point. See, I just bought the bike and I paid with my credit card. And so most, you know, just about any credit card out there will actually has an automatic purchase protection insurance. It's free. You don't have to pay for it or sign up or anything. It doesn't cost any money or anything like that. And if something is lost or stolen or damaged within like, I think it's a hundred days, your credit card company will actually reimburse you.
好吧，他们还挺客气的。是啊。所以，这真的很糟糕，但这其实引出了一个非常有趣的观点。你看，我刚买的自行车，是用信用卡支付的。所以大多数，你知道，几乎任何信用卡其实都有自动购买保护保险。这是免费的。你不需要付费或注册任何东西。它不花任何钱。如果东西在，我想是 100 天内丢失、被盗或损坏，你的信用卡公司实际上会赔偿你。
So you can actually – you could buy – let's say you bought – let's say we went and bought this watch. We paid with our credit card. And we throw the watch off a bridge. Well, be careful. I don't know if you actively throwing it away might change things. Yeah, I guess you can't be that bad. If it fell off and got crushed. Yeah, if it fell off your wrist off a
所以你实际上——你可以买——假设你买了——假设我们去买了这块手表。我们用信用卡支付。然后我们把手表扔下桥。好吧，小心点。我不知道你主动扔掉它是否会有影响。是的，我想你不能做得那么过分。如果是掉下去摔碎了。是的，如果它从你手腕上掉下
bridge or yeah i get crushed under a car or something even though it's it's uh an accident and um even though it's like technically it's i guess it's nobody's fault but i mean the fact is it's not um you know the manufacturer's fault or anything like that um they'll still refund you the money so i have another friend that this happened to. He bought an Xbox and someone actually broke in his house and stole, well, they stole his Xbox and his TV. But because he had bought the Xbox within 100 days, he got reimbursed for that. So if ever something like that happens,
桥，或者被车压碎了之类的，即使这是个意外，而且，嗯，即使从技术上讲，我想这不怪任何人，但事实是，这不怪制造商之类的，他们仍然会退还你的钱。所以我有个朋友也遇到过这种情况。他买了台 Xbox，有人闯进他家偷走了他的 Xbox 和电视。但因为他在 100 天内买了 Xbox，他得到了赔偿。所以如果发生类似的事情，
definitely take advantage of that. Well, at least check. It's worth checking then for sure. Yeah, yeah. I mean, we had to file a police report and you know a bunch of other things so um you know it's not just a uh what's the word i guess it's not a panacea it won't cure all your problems but yeah it's not a free pass that's right yeah but it's definitely something good to know so that you can check on it if it ever happens to you which hopefully yeah yeah definitely keep that in mind so i'm kind of
一定要利用这一点。好吧，至少查一下。那肯定值得一查。是的，是的。我的意思是，我们必须去报警，还有其他一堆事情，所以，嗯，你知道，这不仅仅是一个，怎么说呢，我想这不是万灵药，它不能解决你所有的问题，但是的，它不是一张免费通行证。没错，是的，但这绝对是件好事，这样如果以后发生在你身上，你可以去查一下，希望，是的，是的，一定要记住这一点。所以我有点
glad that uh whoever had that intention was quick about it because if they had waited another like month or so then i wouldn't have been able to use this option so so yeah it kind of sucks but uh you know i can uh i have my wife's bike that i can use to get to work and it's pink and has a little horn and those little frill things outside it has one of those baskets because she uses it to go to like to the supermarket and stuff oh so yeah it has a basket it has this like really like soft flat cushy seats powerpuff girls on the wheels i guess your wife isn't like oh i was gonna say a really young age but that would sound really bad so anyways
庆幸那个有这种意图的人动作很快，因为如果他们再等一个月左右，我就没法使用这个选项了。所以，是的，这真的很糟糕，但，你知道，我可以，我可以用我妻子的自行车去上班，它是粉红色的，有个小喇叭，外面还有那些小流苏，它还有个篮子，因为她用它去超市之类的。哦，所以，是的，它有个篮子，还有那种非常柔软、平坦、舒适的座椅，轮子上还有飞天小女警的图案。我想你妻子不是那种，哦，我本来想说年纪很小，但那听起来会很糟糕。所以，总之，
she she uh it is green. It's kind of like a green mountain bike. So she's not a girl to girly girl, which is nice. It's not like the pink DS that I have to put up with. Um, but, uh,
她，它其实是绿色的。有点像绿色的山地车。所以她不是那种特别女性化的女孩，这很好。不像我必须忍受的那个粉色 DS。嗯，但是，嗯，
so yes, that's the bad news. So are you doing anything cool for 4th of July? Yeah. So by the time people are listening to this, we'll already have done it. So future me in the past is doing has done that's right uh yeah i already hang out hung out with uh some my in-laws uh yesterday so that was good
所以是的，这就是坏消息。那么你 7 月 4 日有什么酷的计划吗？是的。等人们听到这个的时候，我们已经过完了。所以过去的未来的我正在做，已经做了。没错，嗯，是的，我昨天已经和一些姻亲聚过了，所以那很好。
and i had a good time there we played some board games uh wits and wagers which is fun and we played some we uh which my grandmother came over and she beat me at some of the we games uh which is really embarrassing ones i never played before so i didn't really know what I was doing. And that's just an excuse. So she's really old and she beat me. So if you're listening, Grandma, congratulations again. I'm still mourning that loss. And so that was a lot of fun. And then we had some barbecue. And tomorrow going over to my parents and grandparents and uh probably do some more barbecue and hanging out maybe we'll play some board games and stuff so uh i don't think we're doing any fireworks or whatever i used to be really into that when i was younger uh even
我玩得很开心，我们玩了一些桌游，比如《Wits and Wagers》，很有趣。我们还玩了一些 Wii，我祖母过来了，她在一些 Wii 游戏里打败了我，这真的很尴尬，因为我以前从没玩过，所以不知道自己在干什么。那只是借口。所以她年纪很大了，却打败了我。如果你在听，祖母，再次祝贺你。我还在为那次失败哀悼。所以那真的很有趣。然后我们吃了烧烤。明天要去我父母和祖父母那里，可能会再吃点烧烤，聚一聚，也许我们会玩些桌游之类的。所以，嗯，我不觉得我们会放烟花什么的。我年轻的时候很喜欢那个，即使
though my parents said it was kind of like burning dollars and i might as well just like money on fire they were pretty harsh about it uh anyways but yeah we used to do crazy stuff like make napalm and we used to buy the magnesium strips and make fireworks uh yeah nowadays you probably get in trouble with the patriot act all that stuff but uh oh that's true it's true you know nowadays things have become very tame like i uh i went to get a chemistry set for my cousin's kid it's his birthday and uh it actually advertised that you could eat everything in the chemistry set that was a good thing yeah it's like everything's edible and i'm like what you know i had a chemistry set when i was a kid and it had wool stuff for example stuff to make
我父母说那简直是在烧美元，我不如直接把钱点着了。他们对此很严厉。总之，但是的，我们过去常做些疯狂的事，比如制造凝固汽油弹，我们常买镁条来制造烟花。是的，现在你可能会因为《爱国者法案》之类的惹上麻烦。但哦，那是真的，那是真的。你知道，现在事情变得非常温和了。我，我给我表弟的孩子买了一套化学实验套装，那是他的生日礼物，而且它居然宣传说你可以吃掉化学套装里的所有东西。那是个好东西。是的，就像所有东西都是可食用的。我说，什么？你知道，我小时候有一套化学套装，它有，比如，制造
fireworks and i'm pretty sure that stuff's not edible so things have become much more tame so it's kind of a sad thing i know you can still do, at least in Florida, they still have model rockets, so that's kind of cool. Yeah, I think they have that here. But I know that's quickly kind of fading away too, which is kind of sad. Yeah, it's a shame. What are you doing for the weekend? Oh, so we're actually going to go into the city. We're going to go to San Francisco, and we're going to see, they have a firework show and, uh, we're probably gonna try
烟花的东西，我敢肯定那些东西是不能吃的。所以事情变得温和多了，这有点令人难过。我知道你仍然可以，至少在佛罗里达，他们还有模型火箭，所以那挺酷的。是的，我想这里也有。但我知道那也在迅速消失，这有点令人难过。是的，真可惜。你周末打算做什么？哦，我们其实打算进城。我们要去旧金山，我们要去看，他们有烟花表演，而且，嗯，我们可能会试着
and, uh, you know, grab some food and check out the, uh, museum of modern art and stuff like that. Oh, cool. So I guess we should explain for anybody not, uh, from the U S who's might be listening, since I like to think that we have listeners who are international. Um, yeah, for sure. But yeah, so 4th of July is, uh, the independence of the of the U.S. from the rule of Great Britain. And so on the 4th of July, we celebrate that typically with like fireworks and a day off of work and grilling and barbecuing, that kind of stuff. Yep, if we have any listeners from Canada, this is the equivalent to 1st of July or Canada Day. Yep, that's right. But yeah, it's basically a chance
去，嗯，你知道，找点吃的，去看看现代艺术博物馆之类的。哦，酷。所以我想我们应该为任何可能在听的非美国听众解释一下，因为我喜欢认为我们有国际听众。嗯，是的，当然。但总之，7 月 4 日是美国脱离英国统治的独立日。所以在那一天，我们通常会通过放烟花、放假、烧烤之类的活动来庆祝。没错，如果我们有来自加拿大的听众，这相当于 7 月 1 日的加拿大国庆日。是的，没错。但总之，这基本上是一个机会，
for everyone to get together they shoot off some fireworks you um get a chance to sort of uh uh be appreciative for like all things that we have you know this is one of the things that we were talking about today it's like the um it's true that like you get good things and bad things happen like the bike getting stolen things like that but overall, I feel like we're really lucky. And one of the things that makes this place so lucky is that you have open access to technology. You have geeks like us who will tell you about programming. And you have Wikipedia and the opportunity to learn just about anything. And no one's stopping you from learning anything you want and from being as eclectic as
让大家聚在一起，放放烟花，你有机会去，嗯，去感谢我们所拥有的一切。你知道，这是我们今天谈论的事情之一。确实，你会遇到好事，也会有坏事发生，比如自行车被偷之类的，但总的来说，我觉得我们真的很幸运。让这个地方如此幸运的原因之一是你可以自由获取技术。你有像我们这样的极客会告诉你关于编程的事。你有维基百科，有机会学习几乎任何东西。没有人阻止你学习任何你想学的东西，也没有人阻止你像
your capacity so yeah definitely go out there and have some fun and celebrate yeah definitely thankful for all of our soldiers overseas you know protecting our freedom this time so I know there's some controversy there sometimes but definitely supporting the people who are out there you know in harm's way
你的能力一样博学。所以，是的，一定要走出去，玩得开心，庆祝一下。是的，绝对感谢我们在海外保护我们自由的士兵，你知道，在这个时候。我知道有时候会有争议，但绝对支持那些在外面，你知道，身处险境的人。
so yeah I mean you know different people have their out there you know in harm's way so yeah i mean you know different people have their opinions on you know what is worth risking life for and things like that and with all that aside uh anytime somebody puts their life on the line for anything it uh uh you know it's something that should be taken very seriously and there's a lot of people who are putting a lot on the line to you know keep a lot of this stuff going. So news. Yeah, so on a lighter note.
所以，是的，我的意思是，你知道，不同的人有他们的，在外面，你知道，身处险境。所以，是的，我的意思是，你知道，不同的人对什么值得冒生命危险之类的事情有不同的看法。抛开这些不谈，嗯，任何时候有人为了任何事情冒生命危险，这，嗯，你知道，都是应该被非常严肃对待的事情。有很多人为了让这一切继续下去而付出了很多。所以，新闻。是的，所以，说点轻松的。
So I guess the first news article is one I put in there. And I guess it's not really news. Maybe I should have shifted that farther because now this is going to sound silly. Anyways, but this is an article I read. I guess it actually came out a couple weeks ago. Or at least I saw it a couple weeks ago um or at least i saw it a couple weeks ago and uh it was talking a guy writing about the difference between a developer a programmer and a computer scientist and hopefully i'll get this part right but it's the idea that that was kind of interesting and his his thing was that a computer scientist and he was saying that all of these uh categories these classes
所以我想第一条新闻是我放进去的。我想这其实算不上新闻。也许我应该把它往后挪，因为现在听起来会很傻。总之，这是一篇我读过的文章。我想它其实是几周前出来的。或者至少我是几周前看到的，嗯，或者至少我是几周前看到的，嗯，它在谈论一个家伙写关于开发者、程序员和计算机科学家之间的区别。希望我能把这部分说对，但这想法挺有趣的。他的观点是，计算机科学家，他说所有这些类别、这些阶层
are necessary uh the computer scientist is kind of the the guy who's out there thinking about things he's really math oriented he proves out whether something's optimal or not he has elite math skills but in leet speak he has 31 337 math skills yes that's awesome if nothing else everyone should read this article just for that that's pretty epic uh and then uh a programmer is kind of the step down somebody who's still you know into the architecture and the you know higher level programming they're very efficient at things they may not know how to prove it uh emphatically guaranteed that this is the best but they uh they know about how it is and they've got kind of maybe one or two areas where they're really really experts at and they're good at everything but you know kind of key then a developer who I guess it might I might
都是必要的。计算机科学家是那种在外面思考问题的人，他非常注重数学，他证明某样东西是否最优，他有顶尖的数学技能，用 leet 语来说，他有 31 337 的数学技能。是的，太棒了。如果没别的，每个人都应该读读这篇文章，就为了这一点。这太史诗了。然后，嗯，程序员算是低一级，仍然，你知道，沉迷于架构和高级编程的人。他们做事非常高效，他们可能不知道如何证明，断言这就是最好的，但他们，嗯，他们知道它是怎么回事，而且他们可能有一两个领域是真正的专家，他们什么都擅长，但你知道，有点关键。然后是开发者，我猜我可能会
change this and say kind of coder but a developer is actually a little more higher than what I would consider just a coder but a developer is somebody who writes code but they're kind of like a generalist they just work and they're really good at the art of writing code as opposed to, you know, necessarily the algorithms or data structures. And so they're more used to working with like maybe frameworks and the glue code and integration of stuff and kind of testing. And so he is saying that, you know, there's always these three different classes that, you know, they're kind of related, they have a lot of overlap. And it was just kind of an interesting thing. It made me think about, yeah, you and I have had this conversation before about the different classes of people in the programming world and about how all of them are necessary.
改一下，说成是编码员，但开发者实际上比我所认为的仅仅是编码员要高一点。但开发者是那种写代码的人，但他们更像是通才，他们只是工作，他们非常擅长写代码的艺术，而不是，你知道，必然是算法或数据结构。所以他们更习惯于使用，比如框架、胶水代码、东西的集成和测试。所以他说，你知道，总是有这三个不同的阶层，你知道，它们是相关的，有很多重叠。这只是一个有趣的事情。这让我想到，是的，你和我以前谈过编程世界里不同阶层的人，以及他们所有人都是必要的。
But some are probably considered more highly than others. Janitors are really important. We really need janitors, but people don't always give them the respect they deserve. And I think some of the classes of computer programmers are similar. Yeah, definitely.
但有些人可能被认为比其他人更高。清洁工真的很重要。我们确实需要清洁工，但人们并不总是给予他们应有的尊重。我认为某些类别的计算机程序员也是类似的。是的，绝对。
I think that it's a really good point. And the other part of it that's really interesting is that, you know, a computer scientist is, it's really interesting to think about how experience relates to this like experience versus versus knowledge you know a computer scientist could have a lot of knowledge not necessarily so much experience yeah that's a good point but they're not at the same time they
我认为这是一个很好的观点。另一部分非常有趣的是，你知道，计算机科学家，思考经验如何与这种知识相关联，这真的很有趣。你知道，计算机科学家可能有很多知识，但不一定有那么多经验。是的，那是个好观点。但他们不是，同时他们
they need that experience so a computer science with experience is still a lot more useful than one without even though they're doing a lot of theoretical yeah and uh so you know same for all of these is that there's just this balance you have to strike between, you know, getting a lot of these skills, you know, picking your path and gaining experience in that path, but also having a wide breadth of knowledge. And I think it's somewhat of that plays into what happens to everybody first day on the job. You know, I remember first day on the job as a computer science guy guy you know not not a summer job where i was just uh you know flipping
需要那种经验。所以一个有经验的计算机科学家仍然比没有经验的更有用，即使他们做了很多理论研究。是的，嗯，所以，你知道，对所有这些来说都是一样的，就是你必须在获取很多这些技能、你知道，选择你的道路并在该道路上获得经验，以及拥有广泛的知识之间取得平衡。我认为这在某种程度上与每个人上班第一天发生的事情有关。你知道，我记得作为计算机科学专业的人上班的第一天，你知道，不是那种我只是，你知道，翻
burgers or whatever but um first job actually you know in the career workforce and you kind of get in there and you know first few days you're really timid you don't say much uh i'm kind of outspoken guy and so uh you know after a few days you start saying stuff trying to you know show that you know what's going on and then for a while you think wow i'm smarter than all these people and then a little bit more time goes on you realize you probably have knowledge about things they don't you know newer stuff that they maybe don't know about yet or haven't looked into but they have a lot of experience that uh teaches them how and when are the best ways to apply those bits of knowledge. Yeah, definitely. Yeah, I mean, they have a lot of, one key thing of it is that they have many
汉堡之类的暑期工作，而是，嗯，职业生涯中的第一份工作。你进去之后，你知道，头几天你真的很胆怯，话不多。我是一个比较直言不讳的人，所以，嗯，你知道，几天后你开始说话，试图，你知道，展示你知道发生了什么。然后有一段时间你觉得，哇，我比这些人聪明。然后过了一段时间，你意识到你可能拥有他们不知道的知识，你知道，他们可能还不知道或还没研究过的新东西，但他们有很多经验，教导他们如何以及何时是应用这些知识的最佳方式。是的，绝对。是的，我的意思是，他们有很多，其中一个关键点是他们有很多
points of reference. So, you know, you might jump into a project and say, oh, this is going to be a piece of cake. And then you hit this snag and it really throws you off. The next time you go into a project, you're a little bit more wary. You know throws you off the next time you go into a project you're a little bit more wary you know you say oh you know i'm not going to say this is going to take me a week because there's a chance that i might hit some snag or or you know last time i hit this snag so this time i'm going to look and see if the future is going to be rocky like if this can happen again yeah and if there's a chance that it can happen again i'm going to make sure that people know about it you know there are things that you can only learn from
参考点。所以，你知道，你可能会跳进一个项目，说，哦，这简直是小菜一碟。然后你遇到了这个障碍，它真的让你措手不及。下次你进入一个项目时，你会更加谨慎。你知道，让你措手不及，下次你进入一个项目时，你会更加谨慎。你知道，你说，哦，你知道，我不会说这会花我一周时间，因为很有可能我会遇到一些障碍，或者，你知道，上次我遇到了这个障碍，所以这次我会看看未来是否会崎岖不平，比如这种情况是否会再次发生。是的，如果有可能再次发生，我会确保人们知道它。你知道，有些事情你只能从
from learn the hard way i guess yep yep school of hard knocks that's different yeah that's right so i should apologize my voice sounds a little bit funny uh i've been getting over being sick so i apologize i thought it was all the clown training that too uh but riding that unicycle and i tripped and ran into one of those elephant platforms on my trachea it was really bad oh rough but no so i apologize i promise you can't get what i have over the uh podcast so don't worry you don't have to wipe down your headphones but anyways yeah it's not a little bit funny you can't contract diseases through social networking although you are very close to some people and not so close to others yes okay which kind of leads to our next article which is google's social networking platform google plus google plus what google plus plus oh
从中学到，我想是硬碰硬的方式。是的，是的，硬碰硬的学校。那不一样。是的，没错。所以我应该道歉，我的声音听起来有点奇怪。我刚从生病中恢复过来，所以我道歉。我以为那是所有的小丑训练。那也是。但骑那个独轮车，我绊倒了，撞到了气管上的那些大象平台之一，真的很糟糕。哦，粗糙。但不，所以我道歉。我保证你不能通过播客传染我得的病，所以别担心，你不需要擦拭你的耳机。但总之，是的，它不是有点奇怪，你不能通过社交网络感染疾病，尽管你离有些人很近，离有些人不太近。是的，好吧，这引出了我们的下一篇文章，谷歌的社交网络平台 Google Plus。Google Plus 什么？Google Plus Plus 哦，
sounds like a programming language it does maybe maybe they'll have an api and it will be okay but i think that yeah next show is google plus plus now i think that um you know google plus is uh come out and uh you know a bunch of people are getting in on it i believe that they were doing invites but um yeah it's closed frozen invite yeah i'm waiting in that long line so uh yeah same here i guess they're going to reopen invites pretty soon but i did look at a bunch of the like videos and stuff other people who were in had posted yeah yeah definitely you know one of the things that is just really from what i understand i've seen a few news articles on it and the big fundamental
听起来像一种编程语言。确实，也许，也许他们会有 API，那会没事的。但我认为，是的，下一期节目是 Google Plus Plus。现在我认为，嗯，你知道，Google Plus 已经出来了，嗯，你知道，一堆人正在加入。我相信他们正在发送邀请，但，嗯，是的，它是封闭的，冻结邀请。是的，我在排长队。所以，嗯，是的，我也是。我猜他们很快会重新开放邀请，但我确实看了很多像视频之类的东西，其他进去的人发布了。是的，是的，绝对。你知道，其中一件事就是，据我所知，我看了几篇关于它的新闻文章，而那个大的基本的
thing that keeps popping out is the idea of the circles where it's now, I think the word is asymmetric. So, you know, in Facebook, it's symmetric. So if I'm friends with Patrick, Patrick's also friends with me. But in Google+, it's asymmetric, which means, you know, I could have Patrick in my friend circle, but he doesn't necessarily have to do the same to me. And so I can post to all of my friends. And when they post to their circles, it may or may not come to me. This is kind of cool because there's a lot of people who might want to friend you. And you either don't know them very well or they're acquaintances. And there's other people who are like your family where if you know you're having a baby or something you'd want to tell them
一直冒出来的东西是圈子的概念，现在，我想这个词是不对称的。所以，你知道，在 Facebook 里，它是对称的。所以如果我和 Patrick 是朋友，Patrick 也是我的朋友。但在 Google+ 里，它是非对称的，这意味着，你知道，我可以把 Patrick 放在我的朋友圈里，但他不一定非要对我做同样的事。所以我可以发布给所有的朋友。当他们发布到他们的圈子时，它可能会也可能不会传给我。这挺酷的，因为有很多人可能想加你为好友。你要么不太了解他们，要么他们只是熟人。还有其他人，比如你的家人，如果你知道你要生孩子之类的，你会想告诉他们。
you know so so there's different categories of friends there might be some people who who who know you but you don't know them maybe someone you went to middle school right so like the circles you're tagging people of like what kind of yeah so this way this this the fact that it's asymmetric i I think is actually a huge bonus. I mean, for me, the, the thing that killed Facebook was when my grandma requested to be my friend. I mean, that was kind of the end of Facebook for me. I really didn't, you know, it's like, I can't tell her no, but now I can't post rude jokes on Facebook. And, you know, it just, it just, it gets to the point where it's like, you can't really do anything useful.
你知道，所以，所以有不同类别的朋友。可能有些人认识你，但你不认识他们，也许是你初中同学。所以，就像圈子一样，你给人们贴上标签，比如什么样的，是的，所以这样，这个事实，它是非对称的，我认为实际上是一个巨大的奖励。我的意思是，对我来说，扼杀 Facebook 的事情是当我祖母请求成为我的朋友时。我的意思是，那对我来说基本上是 Facebook 的终点。我真的没有，你知道，就像，我不能拒绝她，但现在我不能在 Facebook 上发粗俗的笑话。而且，你知道，它只是，它只是，到了那种地步，就像，你不能真正做任何有用的事情。
So that would be cool. So definitely something to watch. We'll see how it goes. I guess they've had a couple of forays, and I know that's a big thing for them. They want to get into social networking. And so hopefully this will be different. When I get on, I guess I'll – or you get on. When I get on, we'll be able to give a little bit more detailed report. Yeah, for sure.
所以那会很酷。所以绝对值得关注。我们会看看进展如何。我猜他们已经尝试了几次，我知道这对他们来说是一件大事。他们想进入社交网络。所以希望这次会有所不同。当我进去的时候，我猜我会——或者你进去的时候。当我进去的时候，我们将能够提供更详细的报告。是的，当然。
Say what it's like one interesting thing is um uh historically if you look at things on at google that have been blocked by the chinese government they've been the popular things like like buzz didn't get blocked and wave didn't get blocked by the chinese firewall but google plus was immediately blocked by the chinese firewall oh so maybe they're like precognizant of uh yeah that's right they're forecasting yeah it seems like uh if you use google the chinese firewall as a predictive model so i need to create a hedge fund that has this in mind yeah yeah creative yeah. Speaking of finance and social networkings, our next news article is Zynga
说说它是什么样的。一件有趣的事情是，嗯，嗯，从历史上看，如果你看看谷歌上被中国政府屏蔽的东西，它们都是受欢迎的东西。比如 Buzz 没有被屏蔽，Wave 也没有被中国防火墙屏蔽，但 Google Plus 立即被中国防火墙屏蔽了。哦，所以也许他们有先见之明，嗯，是的，没错。他们在预测。是的，看起来，嗯，如果你使用谷歌，中国防火墙作为一个预测模型，所以我需要创建一个考虑到这一点的对冲基金。是的，是的，有创意。说到金融和社交网络，我们的下一篇新闻文章是 Zynga
going for their initial public offering, which means that they're going to try to sell stock shares of the company in order to make some money. And there's a way for the investors and stuff to cash out. But one of the interesting requirements that the United States has
进行首次公开募股，这意味着他们将试图出售公司的股票以赚取一些钱。这是一种让投资者之类的套现的方式。但美国有一个有趣的要求，
is that in order to be able to do this, in order to be able to sell publicly portions of your company, to do that, the people who regulate that, the Securities Exchange Commission, requires you to release information in a certain manner and in a certain way to basically protect the public
就是为了能够做到这一点，为了能够公开出售你公司的部分股份，要做到这一点，监管机构，证券交易委员会，要求你以某种方式和某种途径发布信息，基本上是为了保护公众，
to know what they're investing in and know that that's been you know kind of regulated in check so people have to they can't lie about how much money they make or be completely secret about what they do and so zynga filing for their ipo means they had to release numbers about like how much money they they make where they make it that kind of stuff it doesn't mean they have to spill all of the details but more details than they have previously and so one thing that was learned is that they have a special contract in place with uh facebook oh so we should explain i guess zynga is the company that does a lot of the social networking games uh on facebook and other places i
让他们知道他们在投资什么，并知道这已经，你知道，被监管和检查了。所以人们必须，他们不能在赚多少钱上撒谎，或者对他们所做的事情完全保密。所以 Zynga 申请 IPO 意味着他们必须发布关于他们赚多少钱、在哪里赚钱之类的数据。这并不意味着他们必须泄露所有细节，但比他们以前泄露的细节要多。所以学到的一件事是，他们与 Facebook 有一份特殊的合同。哦，所以我们应该解释一下，我猜 Zynga 是那家在 Facebook 和其他地方做很多社交网络游戏的公司。我
think now they even do stuff not on Facebook, but like Farmville. Uh, I don't know what the other ones, I actually don't know that I play any Zynga games, but yeah, I think they have one where like you build a city. I don't play any of them either, unfortunately, but,
现在想他们甚至做一些不在 Facebook 上的东西，比如 Farmville。嗯，我不知道其他的，我其实不知道我是否玩任何 Zynga 游戏，但是的，我想他们有一个像你建造城市的游戏。我也不玩任何游戏，不幸的是，但是，
but yeah, they have several. Yeah. Yeah. And I think they have like a, uh, like a poker playing one. They have a whole bunch and their,
但是的，他们有几个。是的。是的。而且我想他们有一个，嗯，像扑克游戏。他们有一大堆，而且他们的，
their key is like, right. Is to have it to where you do better in the game or a portion of the game is getting other people involved so like you and i both being like friends in the game means we both do better because of that but it keeps us both playing the game and then to do like progress faster you can pay money to basically go faster even though the game is free to play normally right yeah it was actually really interesting i was reading another article where they were discussing how they reported the income
他们的关键是，对。是让它变成这样，你在游戏中表现更好，或者游戏的一部分是让其他人参与进来，所以像你和我都在游戏中成为朋友意味着我们都因为那个而做得更好，但它让我们俩都继续玩游戏，然后为了像进步得更快，你可以付钱基本上走得更快，即使游戏通常是免费玩的。对，是的，这其实真的很有趣。我正在读另一篇文章，他们讨论了他们如何报告收入，
and because apparently like they had to because the security exchange commission was kind of like they have all these different very segmented types of income and they actually treated things you buy online, microtransactions, as actual things. So for example, let's say you buy a tractor in Farmville. So they actually count that as a capital investment, as if it's the same as if you bought a tractor from Home Depot or something. So a capital investment versus you paying for a service. So for example, if you buy ads on Google Ads, that's a service. You're paying for them to show you these ads.
因为显然，就像他们必须这样做，因为证券交易委员会有点像，他们有所有这些不同且非常细分的收入类型，他们实际上把你在网上买的东西，微交易，当作实际的东西。所以，例如，假设你在 Farmville 里买了一台拖拉机。所以他们实际上把它算作资本投资，就好像你从 Home Depot 买了一台拖拉机一样。所以是资本投资，而不是你为服务付费。所以，例如，如果你在 Google Ads 上购买广告，那是一项服务。你是在付钱让他们向你展示这些广告。
But when you're buying a tractor, even though it's just ones and zeros, they're considering it a capital investment. And they've estimated how long people play on zynga um the average user i think they said plays 18 months before stopping um so yeah i know isn't that crazy so so they basically said they're leasing you a tractor for 18 months in game but they're treating it as a real tractor on paper well yeah i guess there's there's obligations that come with that right like they can't not have the server excuse Like they can't not have the server.
但当你购买拖拉机时，尽管它只是由 0 和 1 组成的数据，他们却将其视为资本投资。他们估算了人们玩 Zynga 游戏的时长，我想他们说平均用户在停止游戏前会玩 18 个月，所以，是的，我知道，这不是很疯狂吗？所以他们基本上是在游戏里租给你一台 18 个月的拖拉机，但在账面上却把它当作一台真正的拖拉机来处理。嗯，是的，我想这背后是有义务的，对吧？比如他们不能没有服务器。
Excuse me. They can't not have the server that has the tractor on it anymore. Right. That's right. So they're forced to provide the tractor for at least 18 months because they've made this claim on paper and things like that. That's interesting. But, yeah, I think that's pretty cool that Zynga's got kind of their tide so closely with Facebook at this point in time. I've heard the converse as well.
抱歉。他们不能没有那个装有拖拉机数据的服务器了。没错。就是这样。所以他们被迫至少提供 18 个月的拖拉机服务，因为他们在账面上做了这样的声明等等。这很有趣。但是，是的，我觉得 Zynga 在这个时间点与 Facebook 结合得如此紧密，这真的很酷。我也听过相反的说法。
Facebook is alleged to go public soon as well, do their IPO. And people are saying Facebook makes a lot of their money off of Zynga. So this is kind of interesting. These two companies are really symbiotic at this point. Yeah, yeah, definitely. I have kind of an interjection news article. I didn't post this, but I will bring this to everyone's attention. This is kind of a shocker.
据说 Facebook 也很快要上市，进行首次公开募股（IPO）。人们说 Facebook 的很多收入来自 Zynga。所以这很有趣。这两家公司在这一点上确实是共生的。是的，是的，绝对是。我有一个插播的新闻。我没发这个，但我会提请大家注意。这有点令人震惊。
But California, as you know, I moved to the Valley not too long ago. And one thing that California is known for is having a lot of taxes. And they've decided to start charging an online sales tax. Have you heard of this? No, I heard something similar about not people who are associates for like Amazon having to pay taxes on the money they make. So they just stopped having them. But this sounds different. Yeah, basically, if I understand this correctly, and I don't know if it's been passed. It says passed.
但是加州，如你所知，我不久前搬到了硅谷。加州以税收多而闻名。他们决定开始征收在线销售税。你听说过这个吗？没有，我听说过类似的事情，比如像亚马逊的关联方必须为他们赚的钱缴税。所以他们就不再做关联方了。但这听起来不一样。是的，基本上，如果我没理解错的话，而且我不知道它是否已经通过了。上面写着已通过。
So I guess it's been passed it says passed so i guess it's i guess it's it's done but basically if i you know as a california resident buy anything online regardless of what state it's in or anything i have to pay sales tax so um wow that's uh yeah that's really well i feel like i think a lot of a lot of states have had that for a while um but they just really not been enforced yeah that's a good point and this one might be also be equally hard to enforce but i think that um you know this like on the surface your first reaction is you know this sucks because i have to pay more taxes or whatever but looking at like the bigger picture i feel like this is sort of a good thing in terms of the macroeconomics because the brick and mortar places are really just getting shafted. I mean, like if Amazon can sell me something for less because they have this distribution network and it's on demand and they have free shipping with Amazon Prime, which we just talked about, there's not really any reason for these brick and mortar places to exist, you know.
所以我猜它已经通过了，上面写着已通过，所以我猜它已经完成了。但基本上，如果我，你知道，作为一个加州居民，在网上买任何东西，不管它在哪个州，我都必须支付销售税。哇，那真是……是的，那真的……嗯，我觉得很多州已经实行一段时间了，但一直没有真正执行。是的，这是一个很好的观点，这个可能也同样难以执行。但我认为，你知道，表面上看，你的第一反应是这很糟糕，因为我必须支付更多的税之类的，但从大局来看，我觉得从宏观经济角度来看，这其实是一件好事，因为实体店真的受到了不公平的对待。我的意思是，如果亚马逊能因为拥有分销网络、按需供应以及我们刚才提到的亚马逊 Prime 免费送货服务而以更低的价格卖给我东西，那么这些实体店确实没有存在的理由了，你知道。
But yet there is a reason for them to exist because often people want artisans. So for example, you might want fresh produce, like you might want, you know, fruits and vegetables from a local garden instead of getting them, you know, through some distribution center in Kansas, you know. And so by not charging online sales tax, you really sort of screw all of those people essentially, and they can't, you know, they can't function. So, you know, but at the same time, everyone, you know, not really too fond of paying more taxes. So it's really a double edged sword. Yeah, I mean, we could go into this a long long time it's not really the right podcast for it but uh yeah there's a lot of economic considerations and i have actually kind of a lot of opinions about uh online sales tax or not but uh yeah we probably should punt on that so that we don't know that's not why people tuned in yeah yeah good point it could
但它们确实有存在的理由，因为人们通常需要工匠。例如，你可能想要新鲜农产品，比如你可能想要当地花园里的水果和蔬菜，而不是通过堪萨斯州的某个配送中心获取。所以，如果不征收在线销售税，你实际上是在坑害所有这些人，他们无法生存。所以，你知道，但与此同时，每个人都不太喜欢多交税。所以这真的是一把双刃剑。是的，我的意思是，我们可以深入讨论很长时间，但这并不是讨论这个的合适播客，但有很多经济方面的考量。我其实对在线销售税有很多看法，但我们可能应该跳过这个话题，以免……那不是人们收听的原因。是的，好观点，它可能
probably take a long time so no that's good what you said it It just, I don't want to bite on that hook. Yeah. On a lighter note, I was walking to a grocery store in the area, and I happened upon this sign, and the sign was really fascinating. Right in front of a grocery store, it's Site of First Silicon Device and Research Manufacturing Company in Silicon Valley. The research conducted here led to the development of the silicon valley 1956 and little did i know but the uh the uh grocery store right next to my house is the place where the first transistor was built so not invented
会花很长时间，所以不，你说得很好。我只是不想上钩。是的。换个轻松的话题，我当时正走在附近的一家杂货店，偶然看到了一个标志，那个标志非常引人入胜。就在杂货店前面，写着“硅谷第一台硅器件和研究制造公司所在地”。在这里进行的研究促成了 1956 年硅谷的发展。我当时并不知道，但我家隔壁的杂货店竟然是第一台晶体管制造的地方，不是发明的地方，
but like the first ones were produced or whatever right Right. I believe the guy who invented it, he invented it at MIT, but then he moved back to Silicon Valley because he originally went to Caltech, and he moved back home and built and started this company that built the first transistor. Well, that's pretty cool. Yeah, I thought that was pretty neat. So if you have a chance and just want to do some light browsing, check check that out it has a whole history of the transfer read about jason's
而是第一批产品生产的地方，对吧？没错。我相信发明它的人是在麻省理工学院发明的，但他后来搬回了硅谷，因为他最初去的是加州理工学院，他搬回家并创办了这家制造第一台晶体管的公司。嗯，那真的很酷。是的，我觉得那很棒。所以如果你有机会，只是想随便逛逛，去看看那个标志，它有关于晶体管的完整历史，读读杰森的
grocery store yeah are you listed as a notable patron of that grocery store uh not notable well we should go add that yeah we should co-host a programming throwdown there's a regular maybe i'll make my own sign and put it right next to that sign it's time for the tool of the bi-week tool of the bi-week so what's your tool my tool of the bi-week is Evernote
杂货店。你是那家杂货店的知名顾客吗？呃，不算知名。好吧，我们应该去把它加上。是的，我们应该在那里共同主持一次编程聚会。也许我会自己做一个标志，把它放在那个标志旁边。现在是双周工具时间。双周工具。那么你的工具是什么？我的双周工具是 Evernote。
it's still a tool it's kind of a service and a tool mixed into one but it's basically a note taking thing note taking program and it's basically a note-taking uh thing note-taking program and uh it's really nice because it it's supported on a lot of different platforms they have like a one for your pc they have one for your iphone your ipad you know i think they have over android devices maybe even your nook i don't know but they have it for a lot of platforms and uh what it does is
它仍然是一个工具，它是一种服务和工具的混合体，但它基本上是一个笔记工具，一个笔记程序。它基本上是一个笔记工具，一个笔记程序。它真的很棒，因为它支持很多不同的平台。他们有电脑版，有 iPhone 版，有 iPad 版，我想他们还有安卓设备版，甚至可能是 Nook 版，我不知道，但他们有很多平台版本。它的作用是
there's you know mostly like what a note-taking app should be you're able to like you know just say hey this note or that note and uh what it does is it syncs them between so you have like an account and then it syncs them between the different platforms and so that's really nice that you're able to you know make a note in one thing like i might be on my ipad using my ipad on a plane and so i'm not online and i might type a note into my evernote and then um later when i'm on wi-fi it can sync that up with my iphone and then i can have it on my iphone and then if i get on my computer and it's like uh you know something i need to look up online i can bring it up and you know
你知道，主要是笔记应用应该有的功能，你可以说，嘿，这个笔记或那个笔记。它的作用是在不同平台之间同步，所以你有一个账户，它会在不同平台之间同步。这真的很棒，你可以在一个设备上做笔记，比如我可能在飞机上用 iPad，当时没联网，我可以在 Evernote 里写个笔记，然后等我连上 Wi-Fi 后，它就能和我的 iPhone 同步，然后我就可以在 iPhone 上查看了。如果我用电脑，需要在线查找某些东西，我可以把它调出来，你知道，
already have it and just copy and paste the search term or the website or whatever and so that's pretty cool um they also do some interesting things where you can take like audio notes and uh even you can take a picture of something and have that be the note and one of the interesting things about that is they actually run like a ocr optical character recognition and so um when you take a picture of it it'll actually like try to figure out what the text says so it was a handwritten note or i take it like of a like a picture of like a price tag or like a sign or something and then you search through your notes it'll actually return those results oh nice yeah so that's all really cool it's also like a generally really useful uh device to have
已经有了它，只需复制粘贴搜索词或网站之类的。这很酷。他们还做了一些有趣的事情，比如你可以录制音频笔记，甚至可以给某样东西拍张照片作为笔记。其中一个有趣的地方是，他们实际上运行了 OCR（光学字符识别），所以当你拍下照片时，它实际上会尝试识别文字内容。所以如果是一个手写笔记，或者我拍了一个价格标签或标志之类的，当你搜索笔记时，它实际上会返回这些结果。哦，不错。是的，这真的很酷。它通常也是一个非常有用的设备。
um and it's free there is a limit um i think if you use and i don't know what it it's the amount of documents you store or how many you do per month or whatever i've never hit it and i think it goes to like five dollars a month or like 45 50 for the year um if you go above a certain like megabytes of usage per month okay um but i've never hit that so it works really well for what i use it and it's completely fine here it says it says you have to go over a gig so okay yeah those people are probably under that so yeah so i think it's one of those things that almost everybody's under that and just to keep people from abusing it. But, you know, some people choose to support because it is so useful and so cool. So some people choose to go ahead and use it anyways.
而且它是免费的。有一个限制，我想如果你使用……我不知道是存储文档的数量，还是每月处理的数量之类的。我从来没达到过上限。我想如果超过一定限额，每月大约是 5 美元，或者一年 45 到 50 美元。如果你每月使用的兆字节数超过一定限额的话。但我从来没达到过。所以它对我来说运行得很好，完全没问题。这里写着如果你超过 1GB。所以，好吧，那些人可能都在限额之下。所以我想这几乎是每个人都在限额之下的东西，只是为了防止人们滥用。但是，有些人选择支持它，因为它非常有用且酷。所以有些人还是选择使用它。
Oh, the other thing is it does like a geolocation. So when you write a note, you can see where notes were written, which is kind of cool. Oh, yeah, that's really useful. So it's like you find a restaurant that you really want to go to, but not that day. You can just make a little note. And then later on, you can have directions to it or something. Yeah, maybe it'll do that. I don't know.
哦，另一件事是它有地理定位功能。所以当你写笔记时，你可以看到笔记是在哪里写的，这很酷。哦，是的，这真的很有用。所以就像你发现了一家你真的很想去的餐厅，但不是那天。你可以做一个小笔记。然后以后，你可以获得去那里的路线之类的。是的，也许它会那样做。我不知道。
That'd be cool. But I haven't tried that. But it notes where you make the note at. Yeah, well, I mean like if you're in front of the – Like you walk by a restaurant and you say, I really want to – Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. All right.
那会很酷。但我还没试过。但它会记录你做笔记的地方。是的，我的意思是，如果你在……就像你路过一家餐厅，你说，我真的很想……是的，是的。是的，是的。好吧。
What's your tool? That's pretty sweet yeah all right what's your it's pretty sweet man my tool of the bi-week is free nx and actually it's more general it's just nx in general but the the free version is is uh is almost 100 fully functional so uh you can jump on that and basically what this is is a way to do desktop, but it's a way that's extremely efficient. So a lot of people have used, you know, the Windows Remote Desktop or VNC. And the way these programs work is they basically they take screenshots of your desktop. Or I guess another way of looking at it is they make a movie out of your desktop. And so, you know, as you open Windows and move them around and things like that, they're streaming a video of your desktop over to you.
你的工具是什么？那很棒，是的，好吧，你的……那很棒，伙计。我的双周工具是 FreeNX，实际上它更通用，就是 NX 本身，但免费版本几乎是 100% 功能齐全的。所以你可以尝试一下。基本上，这是一种远程桌面方式，但它非常高效。很多人用过 Windows 远程桌面或 VNC。这些程序的工作方式基本上是截取桌面的屏幕截图。或者我想另一种看法是，它们把你的桌面拍成了一部电影。所以，当你打开窗口并移动它们时，它们会把桌面的视频流传输给你。
And because your desktop usually doesn't change that much, you know, they could do this fairly quickly and they could use all this compression and things like that. Now, on the other end, there's something called the X windows system which is the windows system that unix and linux computers use so you know windows has something called aero which when you actually move the windows around on your windows computer you minimize and things like that there's an engine there that's controlling all of that called aero on mac there's one called coco and coco is handling the minimizing and Coco looks pretty cool. When you minimize something it like shrinks down into the bottom right on your Mac and that's all done by Coco.
因为你的桌面通常变化不大，所以它们可以很快地完成，并使用各种压缩技术。现在，在另一端，有一种东西叫 X Window 系统，这是 Unix 和 Linux 电脑使用的窗口系统。所以你知道 Windows 有一种叫 Aero 的东西，当你移动窗口、最小化窗口时，有一个引擎在控制这一切，叫 Aero。在 Mac 上有一个叫 Cocoa，Cocoa 处理最小化。Cocoa 看起来很酷。当你最小化时，它会缩小到 Mac 的右下角，这一切都是由 Cocoa 完成的。
On Linux and Unix machines they have something called X Windows. And X Windows has X forwarding. So what it does is instead of sending all of these, instead of sending a video of your desktop, it sends commands over. So it says, hey, open a window, hey, move this window. Sometimes it will send pictures, like here's a picture, now put this picture on the window over here. But it's mostly, like 99% of it is just commands, text. And you know, just to put it in perspective a dictionary of text like a dictionary with every
在 Linux 和 Unix 机器上，它们有 X Windows。X Windows 有 X 转发功能。所以它的作用不是发送所有这些视频，不是发送桌面的视频，而是发送命令。它说，嘿，打开一个窗口，嘿，移动这个窗口。有时它会发送图片，比如这是一张图片，现在把这张图片放在这边的窗口里。但它主要是，99% 只是命令，文本。你知道，为了让你有个概念，一本字典，一本包含英语中每个
word in the english language and everything it explains would be what would you say patrick like five meg or something of text um good question i should know this oh wait let's do some math here let's see so let's say i'll look it up while you keep going yeah let me just take a guess let's say a dictionary is 50,000 words in it, and each word has like a 100-character definition. Then that's just 4 megs of text, right? So you can write a lot of text for 4 megs, versus 4 meg is just a handful of pictures.
单词及其解释的字典，你会说有多少，帕特里克？5 兆左右的文本？嗯，好问题，我应该知道这个。哦，等等，我们来算算。让我们看看，我边查边说。让我猜猜，假设一本字典有 5 万个单词，每个单词有 100 个字符的定义。那只有 4 兆的文本，对吧？所以 4 兆可以写很多文本，而 4 兆只是几张图片。
So X-forwarding is much, better than than VNC or Windows Remote Desktop but X forwarding has a number of flaws it's very old technology and it doesn't really support you know modern operating systems and modern you know with their fancy effects and things like that so if you run X windows it's not going to look very sharp it's's going to look very dated. So this NX technology is a completely new protocol, and it's been implemented in every architecture. So to do X-Forwarding, you have to be on Mac or Linux.
所以 X 转发比 VNC 或 Windows 远程桌面好得多，但 X 转发有很多缺陷。它是非常古老的技术，并不真正支持现代操作系统和它们那些花哨的效果。所以如果你运行 X Windows，它看起来不会很清晰，会显得非常过时。所以这种 NX 技术是一个全新的协议，它已经在每种架构中实现。要使用 X 转发，你必须在 Mac 或 Linux 上。
But to do NX, you can do NX on Windows. So it's completely cross-platform. And it's much better than VNC and Remote Desktop and all these things for the reasons I mentioned. It's just the compression is much superior. And in addition, it's also secure. It runs over SSH, which means that, for example, let's say you're using VNC or X-Forwarding or any of these, and you're using a browser inside of a remote desktop session. So you're at home or you're at work, let's say, but you're logged into your computer
但要使用 NX，你可以在 Windows 上使用。所以它是完全跨平台的。而且由于我提到的原因，它比 VNC 和远程桌面好得多。它的压缩技术要优越得多。此外，它也是安全的。它通过 SSH 运行，这意味着，例如，假设你正在使用 VNC 或 X 转发或任何这些工具，并且你在远程桌面会话中使用浏览器。所以你在家或在工作，但你登录了家里的电脑，
at home and you're using the internet there for some reason. If you type in your Gmail password, those keystrokes go across the wire unencrypted. So someone listening on the wire in between your work and your home, or someone on your Wi-Fi, if you're at Starbucks or something, can just see your password in plain text. But if you're using NX, everything is encrypted, so they can't do anything like that. Well, there are a lot of ways to encrypt to VNC as well, but the default configuration, yeah. Yeah, you can. We shouldn't allude that anybody using VNC is unsafe. I mean, there's a lot of ways to get around that.
出于某种原因在使用互联网。如果你输入 Gmail 密码，这些按键会以未加密的方式通过网络传输。所以有人在你的工作地点和家庭之间监听，或者有人在你的 Wi-Fi 上，如果你在星巴克之类的，他们可以直接看到你的明文密码。但如果你使用 NX，一切都是加密的，所以他们做不到。嗯，有很多方法可以加密 VNC，但默认配置是……是的。是的，你可以。我们不应该暗示任何使用 VNC 的人都不安全。我的意思是，有很多方法可以绕过这个问题。
Right, and the same is true for X-forwarding and remote desktop. So yeah, I guess that we should add that caveat. But with NX, it's built in. You don't have to do any tunneling or anything like that. It's built from the ground up to run over. Yeah, so it looks like there's clients for almost everything, but it looks like the server, so like what computer you're actually using,
没错，X 转发和远程桌面也是如此。所以是的，我想我们应该加上那个警告。但对于 NX，它是内置的。你不需要做任何隧道之类的。它是从底层构建的，可以在上面运行。是的，所以看起来几乎所有东西都有客户端，但看起来服务器，也就是你实际使用的电脑，
is restricted to Linux and Solaris. Oh, really? Is that, am I, that's the website I'm on. You know what it is? This is correct. So free NX server is a Mac, Linux, or Solaris only to use nx server on windows you have to use the paid one so basically a bunch of nerds made a free version of nx called free nx but they hope they didn't make it for windows oh but if you get okay this another thing. The people who make the paid version of NoNX,
仅限于 Linux 和 Solaris。哦，真的吗？是我在看的那个网站吗？你知道是什么吗？这是正确的。所以 FreeNX 服务器仅限 Mac、Linux 或 Solaris。要在 Windows 上使用 NX 服务器，你必须使用付费版本。所以基本上是一群极客制作了一个叫 FreeNX 的免费版 NX，但他们希望……他们没为 Windows 制作。哦，但如果你得到……好吧，这是另一件事。制作付费版 NoNX 的人，
they have a free version as well, the NX free edition. And they have, I believe they have a server for Windows maybe. And, oh, no, they don't either. Wow, that's surprising. All right, well, but if it's for a computer that you have, you should check it out for sure. Yeah, definitely. Well, but if it's for a computer that you have, you should check it out for sure. Yeah, definitely.
他们也有一个免费版本，NX 免费版。我相信他们可能有一个 Windows 服务器。哦，不，他们也没有。哇，这很令人惊讶。好吧，但如果是为你拥有的电脑，你一定要去看看。是的，绝对。好吧，但如果是为你拥有的电脑，你一定要去看看。是的，绝对。
I mean, if you're running OSX or Linux and you want to get at your computer across the network or something like that. And so it works really well, not a lot of lag or anything? No, it works extremely well. It has a setting where you can sort of dial it down based on the amount of bandwidth that you have and I recommend this is a good point I actually recommend putting it on the middle setting so even though you know for example going from my desktop to my server inside my own house I had it on the max setting and that wasn't a problem but I noticed that if I put it on the third setting, the internet usage went down dramatically, and it looks almost exactly the same. So I think on the highest setting, it's not even compressing the images. Like, it's just raw images.
我的意思是，如果你运行 OSX 或 Linux，并且想通过网络访问你的电脑之类的。它运行得很好，没有太多延迟吗？不，它运行得非常好。它有一个设置，你可以根据你的带宽量来调节它。我推荐……这是一个很好的观点，我实际上建议把它放在中间设置。所以即使，例如，从我的桌面到我房子里的服务器，我把它放在最高设置，那也没问题。但我注意到如果我把它放在第三个设置，互联网使用量大幅下降，而且看起来几乎一模一样。所以我认为在最高设置下，它甚至没有压缩图像。就像是原始图像。
But in the middle, it uses, like, a lossless compression. So you really, you know, have nothing to lose by going there. Awesome. There are a couple of threads talking about how there's no NX server on Windows. Okay, so maybe that part wasn't completely correct, Jason. Yeah, sorry about that. We actually said something wrong. This actually is extremely rare. We usually only say something wrong.
但在中间设置，它使用无损压缩。所以你真的没什么可损失的。太棒了。有几个帖子讨论了为什么 Windows 上没有 NX 服务器。好吧，所以也许那部分不完全正确，杰森。是的，抱歉。我们确实说错了什么。这其实非常罕见。我们通常只说错一次。
That's a bold statement, sir. I think this might be the first time. Oh, shit! We should have a cake. We're going to get hate mail. No, but it looks like... I think some people are working on NX server on Windows, but it doesn't look like it's there.
那是一个大胆的声明，先生。我想这可能是第一次。哦，该死！我们应该吃个蛋糕。我们会收到仇恨邮件的。不，但看起来……我想有些人正在开发 Windows 上的 NX 服务器，但看起来还没完成。
But if you have a Linux server... And why don't you have a Linux server? You should definitely be running an X server. If you're a guy who's been using X forwarding or VNC, definitely check this out. Yeah, very cool. I think that's it. So is it time for a prologue? I think it's time for some prologue.
但如果你有一个 Linux 服务器……为什么你没有 Linux 服务器？你绝对应该运行一个 X 服务器。如果你是一个一直使用 X 转发或 VNC 的人，一定要看看这个。是的，非常酷。我想就是这样。那么是时候进行序言了吗？我想是时候进行一些序言了。
So prologue is definitely a computer scientist's language. So what does prologue stand for? You got to start off. I don't know. definitely a computer scientist's language so developers are programmers here you gotta start off i don't know i think it stands for programmable logic but i don't i don't think it that's right yeah i don't think it actually doesn't actually stand for anything no it's yeah for programming logic yeah but uh that's definitely what it is. And so to talk about programming or to talk about Prolog, we have to talk about predicate calculus, specifically first-order predicate calculus and first-order logic. Well, so why did you say it was a computer scientist program? Are you going to tell us that?
所以 Prolog 绝对是计算机科学家的语言。那么 Prolog 代表什么？你得先开始。我不知道。绝对是计算机科学家的语言，所以开发者是这里的程序员。你得先开始。我不知道，我想它代表可编程逻辑，但我认为那不对。是的，我不认为它实际上代表任何东西。不，它是……为了编程逻辑，是的，但那绝对是它的含义。所以要谈论编程或谈论 Prolog，我们必须谈论谓词演算，特别是一阶谓词演算和一阶逻辑。那么，你为什么说它是计算机科学家的程序？你要告诉我们吗？
Yeah, yeah, definitely. It's a bold statement. Okay, all right. Yeah, so this is going to be pretty geeked out but we're gonna you know break it down and we're gonna to to you know explain all the details but there's something called well first there's something called logic and logic comes down to many different things but but one of two of those things are deductive and inductive reasoning so can you give me an example of inductive reasoning so inductive reasoning is
是的，是的，绝对。这是一个大胆的声明。好吧，好吧。是的，这会非常极客，但我们会把它拆解，我们会解释所有的细节。但有一种东西……首先，有一种东西叫逻辑，逻辑归结为许多不同的东西，但其中两件事是演绎推理和归纳推理。你能给我一个归纳推理的例子吗？所以归纳推理是
building up from something smaller right so like inductive reasoning would be like dogs have oh that's a bad example i'm trying to think of an example that's uh that's gonna always be true and not just in a restrained example but uh i only go outside when it's raining. It's currently raining. So I go out. I only go outside when it's not raining. It's currently raining. So I won't go outside. Did I get it right? Yeah, kind of.
从较小的东西建立起来，对吧？所以归纳推理就像是狗有……哦，那是个糟糕的例子。我试着想一个总是正确的例子，而不是在一个受限的例子中。但我只在下雨时才出门。现在正在下雨。所以我出门。我只在不下雨时才出门。现在正在下雨。所以我不会出门。我做对了吗？是的，算是吧。
That's kind of. That's a bad example. Do you have a better one? Yeah. So, for example, inductive reasoning is essentially guessing. So let's say, for example, okay, I live in Silicon Valley and it rains like 0.1 centimeter for the entire month of July. Like it never rains in July statistically. So that is an inductive statement.
那算是。那是个糟糕的例子。你有更好的吗？是的。例如，归纳推理本质上是猜测。所以，假设，好吧，我住在硅谷，整个七月份只下了 0.1 厘米的雨。七月份在统计学上几乎从不下雨。所以这是一个归纳陈述。
So, you know, it has rained in July at some point, you know, maybe 25 years ago or something, but it's so infrequent that I induce that tomorrow it's not going to rain, which is, you know, it can be wrong. It's not, it's not, you know, 100% true, but I'm making an assumption. I'm inducing that it's not going to rain tomorrow based on all this prior history of it, you know, never raining in July or raining so infrequently. So, okay, so you're making a prediction about the future. Right. That would be induction. Okay. Now, deduction is where you deduce, where you come up with new facts based on existing data but deduction doesn't involve
所以，你知道，七月份在某个时候下过雨，也许是 25 年前之类的，但它太罕见了，所以我归纳出明天不会下雨，这（你知道）可能是错的。它不是 100% 正确的，但我做了一个假设。我根据过去七月份从不下雨或下雨极少的历史，归纳出明天不会下雨。所以，好吧，你在对未来做预测。没错。那将是归纳法。好的。现在，演绎法是你推导的地方，你根据现有数据得出新的事实，但演绎法不涉及
any guessing so for example um you know uh all mammals have hair and patrick and i are mammals last time we checked and so therefore we did we deduce that we have hair because we are in the set of mammals, and anything that's in the set of mammals has hair. So, you can think of this as like a transitive property. Like we are in class A, and class A implies fact X. Therefore, we have fact X. Yeah, that was what I was doing. Your deduction.
任何猜测。例如，嗯，你知道，所有哺乳动物都有毛发，帕特里克和我上次检查时是哺乳动物。因此，我们推导出我们有毛发，因为我们属于哺乳动物集合，而任何属于哺乳动物集合的东西都有毛发。所以，你可以把它看作传递属性。就像我们在 A 类中，A 类暗示事实 X。因此，我们有事实 X。是的，那是我刚才做的。你的演绎。
I messed that up. I got it wrong. Yeah, no worries. Tell me I was wrong. All right, second time. Crap. In one episode. In one episode, man. Sorry. What the heck? All right. deduction i messed that up i got it wrong tell me i was wrong all right second time crap in one episode in one episode man what the heck all right so anyways uh so from this you can deduce that i'm
我搞砸了。我弄错了。是的，别担心。告诉我我错了。好吧，第二次。该死。在一集里。在一集里，伙计。抱歉。怎么回事？好吧，好吧，所以无论如何，从这里你可以推导出我
never wrong and patrick is wrong twice you have to induce about it but you could actually i was wrong the first um so uh so okay so now we have deduction first order logic is based on deduction so you might say the mammals example would be fine so to explain the mammals example in first order predicate calculus you would say for all X where X is a mammal and then you draw an arrow which means implication that implies that x has hair or has hair as a function with x in parentheses so if the has mammal function can run on x is true on the variable x then the has hair function is also true on the variable X. Does that make sense? Yeah. Yeah, so that's first order predicate calculus. Now you can, then you can say, let's say X is Patrick and let's say is mammal Patrick is true. And
永远不会错，而帕特里克错了两次。你必须对此进行归纳，但你实际上可以……我第一次错了……所以，好吧，现在我们有了演绎法。一阶逻辑是基于演绎法的。所以你可能会说哺乳动物的例子很好。为了用一阶谓词演算解释哺乳动物的例子，你会说对于所有 X，如果 X 是哺乳动物，然后你画一个箭头，这意味着蕴含，这意味着 X 有毛发，或者“有毛发”是一个以 X 为参数的函数。所以如果“是哺乳动物”函数在变量 X 上运行为真，那么“有毛发”函数在变量 X 上也为真。这有意义吗？是的。是的，这就是一阶谓词演算。现在你可以说，假设 X 是帕特里克，假设“是哺乳动物”帕特里克为真。并且
this, if following first order predicate logic, you can deduce that has hair, Patrick, is also true based on the law that we set up, the inference that we set up. So with all that said, Prolog is a programming language specifically targeted at implementing first-order predicate logic and doing deductions. So what does the first order means there it means you don't make two jumps in conclusion it means you just make one is that what the first order means um oh i used to know this let me know it's okay well here you you could talk about maybe the history of prologue and i'll look up second order logic. So Prologue's actually pretty old. It's not new. It's been around for a while, since the 70s. It was invented by a guy named Alan,
如果遵循一阶谓词逻辑，你可以推导出“有毛发”帕特里克也为真，基于我们建立的法则，我们建立的推理。综上所述，Prolog 是一种专门针对实现一阶谓词逻辑和进行演绎的编程语言。那么那里的一阶是什么意思？它意味着你不会在结论中跳跃两次吗？它意味着你只做一次吗？一阶是什么意思？嗯，哦，我以前知道这个。让我知道。没关系。好吧，你可以谈谈 Prolog 的历史，我去查查二阶逻辑。所以 Prolog 其实很老了。它不新。它已经存在一段时间了，从 70 年代开始。它是由一个叫艾伦的人发明的，
oh, I'm going to mess this up, Cole Moreau and Philip Roussel. And it was, I think it was really, like you said, it's a computer scientist paper. So I mean, there's a lot of people kind of doing this kind of logic and this kind of reasoning and saying that computers should be as well and so somebody actually finally came up with the idea of having this this programming language to implement it this way called prologue and they were able to do that the first ones were you know
哦，我要搞砸了，科尔·莫罗和菲利普·鲁塞尔。我想这真的像你说的，这是一篇计算机科学家的论文。所以我的意思是，很多人都在做这种逻辑和这种推理，并说计算机也应该这样做。所以终于有人想出了这个主意，用这种方式实现这种编程语言，叫 Prolog。他们能够做到这一点，第一批是，你知道
we talked about this about more early, early it was an interpreted language. Later, you know, kind of people were able to figure out ways of actually like doing more compilation type stuff. And it kind of grew over time. It's been around. I mean, it's still used a lot in universities and stuff. And it's never really faded away and kind of gone away like some languages do. But it's never really gone mainstream, I don't think.
我们之前谈过这个，早期它是一种解释型语言。后来，人们能够想出更多编译类型的方法。它随着时间的推移而发展。它一直存在。我的意思是，它在大学里仍然被大量使用。它从未真正像某些语言那样消失。但我认为它从未真正进入主流。
I mean, it's never had a time when it was the most commonly used or even a significant portion of programming was done in it. Yeah, I mean, there was actually a time when, and there's some people to this day who believe that first-order predicate logic is the key to sort of unlocking all the mysteries of the universe. And this was sort of the key to reaching human level intelligence so people in the 60s and 70s really believe this and um you'll find guys like minsky and whatever that still kind of believe this they're very kind
我的意思是，它从未有过成为最常用语言的时期，甚至没有在编程中占据重要比例。是的，我的意思是，实际上曾经有一段时间，直到今天仍有一些人相信一阶谓词逻辑是解锁宇宙所有奥秘的关键。这曾经是达到人类水平智能的关键，所以 60 年代和 70 年代的人真的相信这一点。你会发现像明斯基之类的人仍然相信这一点，他们非常
of set in their ways and but you you ever see like you know space odyssey 2001 that movie with hal the robot? No. It takes over the ship. Go ahead. But yeah, basically in the 60s and the 70s, in fact, several famous computer theoreticians are quoted as saying, we'll have human-level intelligence within our lifetimes implemented in the computer. And so there's a time where people believed that deduction and induction were the key to getting human-level intelligence. And, of course, now we understand that that's not the case, that knowledge itself involves very high-level structures. And this sort of gets us on a tangent. engine. But regardless, during that time, you know, prologue and other predicate languages were
固执己见。但你有没有看过《2001 太空漫游》，那部有哈尔机器人的电影？没有。它接管了飞船。继续。但是的，基本上在 60 年代和 70 年代，事实上，几位著名的计算机理论家曾断言，我们将在有生之年实现计算机的人类水平智能。所以有一段时间，人们相信演绎和归纳是获得人类水平智能的关键。当然，现在我们明白事实并非如此，知识本身涉及非常高级的结构。这让我们偏离了主题。但无论如何，在那段时间，你知道，Prolog 和其他谓词语言
extremely popular because, you know, a lot of people with a lot of money believed that they were going to get human level brain like intelligence from them. But yeah, since then, it's really kind of died down in popularity, but they do have their applications. So that's interesting. So the knowledge thing now, we should kind of point out here that your background is in artificial intelligence. So this is right up your alley. Not so much up mine. So if I sound like an idiot, because I am on this topic. It goes both ways. Like with assembly, we were definitely asking you how to add. So showing the strengths, everybody has their kind of strengths. So this is up your alley. But now I know a lot people talk about expert systems
非常流行，因为很多有钱人相信他们会从中获得人类水平的大脑智能。但从那以后，它的流行度确实下降了，但它们确实有应用场景。这很有趣。所以关于知识的事情，我们应该指出，你的背景是人工智能。所以这正是你的专长。不是我的。所以如果我听起来像个白痴，那是因为在这个话题上我确实是。这双向的。就像汇编语言，我们肯定在问你如何相加。所以展示优势，每个人都有自己的优势。所以这是你的专长。但现在我知道很多人谈论专家系统
yep how does that tie into what you're talking about about knowledge and about people trying to to be as smart as humans or have computers be as smart as humans so let's first let's talk about the answering your question from before first order versus second order yeah so second order so first order logic all the variables are either all or or um or one so in other words i could say uh if if any person is a murderer in the room then everyone is a suspect so it's like i don't know who the murderer is but there's a murderer somewhere in this room everyone is a suspect okay um you know once you get to second order logic then you get into things like sets so in other words for all people who are the set
是的，这和你谈论的关于知识以及人们试图让计算机像人类一样聪明有什么联系？所以让我们先回答你之前的问题，一阶与二阶。是的，二阶……所以一阶逻辑，所有的变量要么是“所有”，要么是“一个”。换句话说，我可以说，如果房间里有任何谋杀者，那么每个人都是嫌疑人。所以就像我不知道谁是谋杀者，但房间里有谋杀者，每个人都是嫌疑人。好的。一旦你进入二阶逻辑，你就会进入集合之类的东西。换句话说，对于所有去过这次旅行的人，那么这些人可能是谋杀者。你进入了非常复杂的东西，它被称为中智逻辑，所以它是基于启发式的，基于启发式，但有概率。换句话说，对于所有去过巨人队比赛的人，他们中有一半经历了这件事。所以现在你有了一个分叉，你有了一个集合。所以二阶非常复杂，而且非常有限。但一阶确实是进行实际操作的核心。那么你的第二个问题是什么？我的第二个问题是专家系统。没错，专家系统。所以根据定义，专家系统是使用演绎法和不同规则来创建大量事实的系统。这是专家系统的核心。
of people who went on this trip then like those people could be murderers you get into just really complicated it's called neutrosophic so it's based on uh you know heuristics based on heuristics but probabilities so in other words for everyone who went to the giants game half of them experience this and so now you have this bifurcation you have this set so second order is very complicated and and very limited um but first order is really kind of where it's at in terms of doing things that are practical. So what was your second question? My second question was expert systems. Right, expert systems. So by definition, expert system is one that uses deduction and different rules to create a lot of facts this is this is the core of an
所以 Prolog 是专家系统的核心，或者说是演绎推理。是的，我错过了这个。哦，好吧，好吧。例如，你可能会想到医疗……这是一个很好的例子，医疗……你知道，不是猜测，而是医疗诊断。好的。例如，你有没有见过这些流程图，比如弄清楚你的孩子得了什么病？如果你的孩子流鼻涕，但在 WebMD 上……那发生在 WebMD 上。如果你去 WebMD，它说点击身体部位……是的，所以如果你的孩子流鼻涕，它会问你另一个问题，比如你的孩子有皮疹吗？如果他有皮疹，那么他得了这种病，如果没有，那么他只是感冒或
expert system so prologue is the core of an expert system or the deduction reasoning yeah i missed what the this is oh oh right right so for example um you might think of a medical this this is this is a good example is medical uh you know not guessing but medical diagnosis okay so for example you might have you seen these flow charts where it's like um you know figuring out what illness your kid has like if your kid has a runny nose but then on webmd that happens on webmd if you go on webmd it says click on the body part where the problem is yeah so it's like so if your kid has a runny nose then it asks you another question like does your kid have rashes and if he does have rashes then he has this disease if not then he just has a cold or
什么的，对吧？所以这是一个专家系统，他们在收集事实。你可以用一阶谓词逻辑来思考这个问题。换句话说，有一个一阶谓词规则说，如果 X……如果 X 的流鼻涕函数为真，并且 X 的皮疹函数为真，那意味着，我不知道，患麻疹函数为真，对吧？我只是编造这些。永远不要用这个播客来诊断你的孩子。这不是医疗建议。是的，所以这是一个例子，
whatever right so so this is an expert system where they're collecting facts you can think of this in first order predicate logic so in other in other words, there's a first-order predicate rule that says, you know, if X, so if the function runny nose for X is true and the function rash for X is true, that implies that the function, I don't know, has measles is true, right? I'm just making these up. Don't ever diagnose your kid with this podcast. This is not medical advice. Yeah, so that is an example of, you know,
一阶逻辑中的一组规则。然后遍历并说，嘿，约翰尼感冒了，约翰尼有皮疹。然后遍历这些规则发现约翰尼患麻疹为真，这就是一个专家系统。好的。现在，有两种实现专家系统的方法。一种是通过前向链，一种是通过后向链。所以我们来谈谈这两种。后向链从所有目标开始，向后推导。例如
a set of rules in first order logic. And then going through and saying, you know, hey, Johnny has a cold and Johnny has a rash. And then traversing through these rules to discover that Johnny has measles is true, that is an expert system. Okay. Now, there's two ways to implement an expert system. One is through forward chaining, and one is through backward chaining. And so we'll talk about both of these. Backward chaining starts at all of the goals and goes backwards so for example
回到我们的……所以让我们从前向链开始，因为那更容易。对于前向链，你会采取……让我们让它稍微复杂一点。如果某人患有麻疹，并且他们有……我不知道，便秘，那么他们实际上有别的东西，他们有禽流感，假设。所以你输入事实，你知道约翰尼患有麻疹，他有便秘，或者不，抱歉，约翰尼流鼻涕，他有……另一个症状是什么？哦，他流鼻涕，他有皮疹，他有便秘。这是你输入到这个 WebMD 专家系统中的三个事实。它向前推导，它说，嘿，如果约翰尼患有麻疹，并且他有这个
going back to our so let's start with forward chaining because that's that's easier so with forward chaining you would take let's say let's make this a little bit more complicated if somebody has a runny nose and or if somebody has measles and they have uh i don't know constipation then they actually have something else they have avian flu let's say so you put in the facts you know johnny has measles he has constipation or no sorry johnny has a runny nose uh he has what was the other thing for me oh he has a runny nose he has a rash and he has constipation those are the three facts that you put into this web md this expert system and it goes forward and it says hey if johnny has measles therefore he and he has this
其他东西，那么他有禽流感。但它还不知道约翰尼患有麻疹，因为它还没有推断出来。那是一个不同的规则。所以它跳过那个规则，说，好吧，我们还不能应用这个规则。我们所知道的是约翰尼感冒了，他有皮疹，他有便秘。他还没有麻疹。所以跳过它。所以它进入下一个规则，它说他有感冒和皮疹吗？哦，他有。因此，他也患有麻疹，对吧？明白了。现在有四件事了。所以它再次遍历这些规则。当它到达那个规则时，如果他有麻疹和便秘，那个规则也会触发。然后现在他有禽流感了。
uh this other thing then he has avian flu but it doesn't know that johnny has measles yet because it hasn't inferred that yet that's a different rule so it skips that rule says well we can't apply this rule yet all we know is that johnny has he has a cold he has a rash and he has constipation he doesn't have measles yet so skip it so it goes to the next rule and it says does he have a cold and a rash oh he does therefore he also has measles right got it now has four things. So then it goes back over again through the rules. And when it gets to that rule where if he has measles and constipation, that rule also fires. And then now he has the avian flu one.
所以这就是前向链，你获取事实，找出有多少规则符合，根据这些规则创建新事实，然后重复这个过程。问题是，规则可能会呈指数级爆炸。所以你最终可能会推断出很多与你想要的无关的事情。例如，假设你想知道，约翰尼有禽流感吗？你不在乎他是否患有麻疹。就像你只想知道这个问题的答案，你可以从那里开始，然后向后推导。
So that's forward chaining where you're taking your facts and you're finding how many of the rules fit, creating new facts based on those rules, and then just repeating this process. The problem with this is, you know, the rules might explode exponentially. So you might end up inferring just tons of things which might have nothing to do with what you want. So for example, let's say you wanted to know, does Johnny have Davian flu? And you don't care if he has measles or not. like you just want to know this one answer to this one question you could start there and go backwards
这就是正向推理，你利用已知事实，找出有多少规则符合条件，根据这些规则创建新的事实，然后不断重复这个过程。这样做的问题在于，规则数量可能会呈指数级爆炸。你最终可能会推导出大量与你想要的结果毫无关系的信息。举个例子，假设你想知道约翰尼是否患有达维安流感，而你并不关心他是否患有麻疹。如果你只想知道这一个问题的答案，你可以从结果出发进行反向推理。
like you could say john somebody anybody not necessarily johnny but a person has the avian flu if they have these two things which was measles and constipation and then you could say a person has measles if they have you know cold symptoms and a rash and you could take the cold systems and the rash and substitute the measles with those two things you see what i'm saying so you're kind of going backwards and substituting things in and you're generating this one like mega rule seems like you're going doing less work that way too you don't have to go through all the rules trying to figure out if they apply. Yeah, yeah, definitely. So, you know, backwards chaining works when you want to find one answer.
比如你可以说约翰、某人、任何人，不一定是约翰尼，如果一个人有这两样东西，即麻疹和便秘，那么他就有禽流感；然后你可以说，如果一个人有感冒症状和皮疹，那么他就有麻疹；接着你可以把感冒症状和皮疹代入，用这两样东西替换掉麻疹。你看我说的意思吗？所以你是在进行反向操作，代入各种事物，从而生成一条“超级规则”。这样看起来工作量也更小，你不必遍历所有规则来判断它们是否适用。是的，确实如此。所以，当你想要找到一个答案时，反向链式推理（backwards chaining）非常有效。
And forward chaining works when you want to just figure out what answers are out there. And so as you can imagine, you can make tons and tons of rules. And people did this. There's something called CYC. let me see what it stands for uh it's called open cyc uh it's just called it's just called uh cyc technology anyways basically what they did was they generated tons and tons of rules. And you can go to opencyc.org.
而当你只是想找出有哪些可能的答案时，正向链式推理（forward chaining）就很有效。你可以想象，你可以创建成千上万条规则。人们确实这么做了。有一个东西叫CYC，让我看看它代表什么……它叫OpenCyc，或者就叫CYC技术。总之，他们基本上生成了海量的规则。你可以访问opencyc.org。
You can actually download the rule database. And these people actually got experts in every single discipline and generated millions and millions of rules. I mean, this was in the 60s and the 70s when people thought that they were going to end up with a brain when they finished this project. And so literally, like, they called ballerinas, famous ball famous ballerinas and they said give us facts about ballerinas and they would say well ballerinas have strong feet and strong legs ballerinas can jump high you know they just kept loading the system full of facts and then it's almost like if you've ever read hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy right they just load the system full of facts and then the expectation is you can say you know uh you know should we increase the taxes or should i should i have should my wife and i have another child and it will somehow use all of these facts and infer
你实际上可以下载这个规则数据库。这些人找来了各个领域的专家，生成了数以百万计的规则。我的意思是，这还是在60年代和70年代，当时人们认为完成这个项目后就能得到一个大脑。所以他们真的找来了芭蕾舞演员，著名的芭蕾舞演员，问她们关于芭蕾舞演员的事实，她们会说，芭蕾舞演员有强壮的脚和腿，芭蕾舞演员能跳得很高。你知道，他们只是不断地往系统里填充事实。这就像如果你读过《银河系漫游指南》，他们只是把系统塞满事实，然后期望你可以问，比如“我们应该增加税收吗？”或者“我和我妻子应该再要一个孩子吗？”，它就会以某种方式利用所有这些事实进行推断。
well based on ballerinas and everything else um you know you know you shouldn't have a child or something like that so i take it this didn't work out so well, because I've never seen one of these machines down at the store where I can buy one or use it. Yeah, exactly. It turns out that, you know, as Patrick said, I've, you know, versed history in AI, but, but to keep it short, basically, predicate logic and rules like these are not the way that knowledge is stored in your brain. It's much more, it's much less opaque, right? You know, I mean, think of like a floor, like when you do navigation around your house or your office or things like that, you don't have a floor plan.
“嗯，根据芭蕾舞演员和其他所有信息，你不应该要孩子”之类的。所以我猜这结果不太好，因为我从来没在商店里见过这种机器，也没法买来用。是的，完全正确。事实证明，正如帕特里克所说，我对人工智能的历史很了解，但长话短说，谓语逻辑和这类规则并不是大脑存储知识的方式。它要模糊得多，对吧？我的意思是，想想地板，比如你在家里或办公室导航时，你并没有一张平面图。
Like you don't really know the thickness of the walls in your house, if you think about it, or the distance, you know, from the wall in your house if you think about it or the distance you know from the wall in your bedroom to whatever room is on the other side the thickness of that the distance of that between 18 feet 6 inches 18 that's pretty thick wall man you have another room there but uh but yeah you don't know this right so it's the way that you navigate in your house is much cloudier than that and it doesn't really use rules so you don't know in advance what you want to know well that's that's another thing true right that's another thing is that you have to sort of learn on the fly and you're constantly generating generating
你并不真正知道家里墙壁的厚度，如果你仔细想想的话；或者距离，你卧室墙壁到另一侧房间的距离，那之间的厚度，18英尺6英寸，那墙可真够厚的，伙计，你那边还有个房间。但确实，你并不知道这些，对吧？所以你在家里导航的方式要模糊得多，而且它并不真正使用规则。所以你并不知道自己预先想知道什么。嗯，那是另一回事，确实，那是另一回事，你必须边走边学，而且你一直在生成……
these rules and tearing some down and using second order logic you know some of the rules you know might exist but you're not sure so other words, if you see a ball falling to the ground and it looks shiny and has that kind of like a marble-ish texture, you're pretty sure it's a bowling ball and it's going to go wham when it hits on the ground. But if you see a ball that's around the same size but it has bumps on it and lines like a basketball, you kind of think that it's going to bounce and if if basketballs didn't bounce over time you would they would train you to think the opposite right so you're constantly building these these models that are based on statistics not based on logic but nonetheless prologue is still extremely useful for building these logic-based systems.
这些规则，推翻一些规则，并使用二阶逻辑。你知道，有些规则可能存在，但你不确定。换句话说，如果你看到一个球掉在地上，它看起来很亮，有一种大理石般的质感，你很确定它是一个保龄球，掉在地上会发出“砰”的一声。但如果你看到一个大小差不多但上面有凸起和线条的球，像篮球一样，你会觉得它会弹起来。如果篮球随着时间推移不再弹跳，它们会训练你产生相反的想法，对吧？所以你一直在构建这些基于统计而非逻辑的模型。但尽管如此，Prolog在构建这些基于逻辑的系统时仍然非常有用。
Because you think about it, the thing that it's doing is it's searching through all these rules. It has a bunch of facts. And you could think of the facts kind of like searching through the internet or searching through doing pathfinding. It all comes down to sort of exploring your options and finding out what the future is like and what other options are out there. And Prologue has a sort of a built-in search engine that is extremely, extremely optimized. So because of that, it is very useful. So it sounds like there's almost two phases here. I guess it's a little bit different than most programming, but you got one where you're kind of building up these statements, these truths, this knowledge, and another one where you're querying it for something. Yeah, exactly.
因为你想想，它所做的事情就是搜索所有这些规则。它有一堆事实。你可以把这些事实想象成在互联网上搜索或进行路径查找。这一切归根结底就是探索你的选择，找出未来是什么样子，以及还有哪些其他选择。Prolog有一个内置的搜索引擎，经过了极度的优化。所以正因为如此，它非常有用。听起来这里几乎有两个阶段。我想这和大多数编程有点不同，你有一个阶段是在构建这些陈述、这些真理、这些知识，另一个阶段是在查询某些东西。是的，完全正确。
That's a huge part of it. So, you know, Prolog is, it's all about, you know, generating the Prolog files with all of your facts and your inferences and then as you said going through later and saying i'm going to give you so i'm you have essentially one thing that makes prologue confusing to new people is that it doesn't differentiate sort of these permanent facts like you know if all mammals have hair and things like that from different statements that you make on the fly like patrick is a mammal or something something like Patrick is a mammal is only useful for that instance where you're talking about Patrick once you're talking about John the stuff about Patrick doesn't really matter and so that's sort of the key to all of this
这是其中很大一部分。所以，Prolog的一切都是关于生成包含所有事实和推论的Prolog文件，然后正如你所说，稍后再去查询。让Prolog对新手来说感到困惑的一点是，它没有区分永久性事实（比如“所有哺乳动物都有毛发”之类）和你在运行中做出的不同陈述（比如“帕特里克是哺乳动物”）。像“帕特里克是哺乳动物”这样的陈述，只在你谈论帕特里克的那次实例中有用。一旦你开始谈论约翰，关于帕特克的内容就不重要了。所以这算是所有这些的关键。
that's something that prologue doesn't quite handle that well which makes it hard to use but but but it's definitely that's definitely an important part of it and uh one thing that's important to note of prologue is it's turing complete so i don't know if we really talked about have we mentioned turing complete yeah i don't know we might need to save that for for another because that could bear a whole lot of discussion yeah that really gets into but let's suffice it to say um you can write any program that's writable in Prolog. Exactly, exactly. But it makes no statement to how hard or easy it is to write it
这是Prolog处理得不太好的地方，这使得它很难使用，但它绝对是其中重要的一部分。还有一点需要注意，Prolog是图灵完备的。我不知道我们是否真的讨论过，我们提到过图灵完备吗？是的，我不知道，我们可能需要把它留到下次，因为那可能需要大量的讨论。是的，那确实深入了，但我们只需说，你可以用Prolog编写任何可编写的程序。没错，没错。但这并不说明编写它的难度或容易程度，
or how long or fast or slow it might be. That's right, that's right. So, you know, you can actually implement sorting. You can do file I.O. You can do anything in Prolog that you can do in another language. But keep in mind that it's geared to doing this first-order predicate logic. This gets into something a little interesting, which is the idea of bindings. And we haven't talked about this either, but I'll just mention it briefly.
或者它运行得有多快或多慢。没错，没错。所以，你可以实现排序，可以进行文件I/O，可以在Prolog中做任何你在其他语言中能做的事情。但请记住，它是为了进行这种一阶谓语逻辑而设计的。这引出了一个有趣的话题，即绑定的概念。我们还没谈过这个，但我会简要提一下。
Many languages have bindings for other languages. And so what that means is, let's say I'm writing some kind of application to do an expert system. Like this WebMD is a perfect example. So, you know, the expert system part where I collect the facts of the patients and I make inferences of whatever, you know, ailments they might have. You want that to be done in Prolog because you don't want to have to write your own expert system and see your C++ or Java. You know, Prolog does it way better than any of us could ever do it. But at the same time, you're writing an application for the web. So, I mean, it's going to be done in JavaScript or on the back end in a web server like Python or C++.
许多语言都有针对其他语言的绑定。这意味着，假设我正在编写某种应用程序来构建专家系统。比如WebMD就是一个完美的例子。所以，专家系统部分，我收集病人的事实并推断他们可能患有什么疾病。你希望这部分用Prolog完成，因为你不想在C++或Java中编写自己的专家系统。你知道，Prolog做得比我们任何人都好。但同时，你正在为Web编写应用程序。所以，它将用JavaScript完成，或者在后端用Python或C++的Web服务器完成。
So Prolog has what's called bindings where you can create a Prolog environment and run Prolog functions from inside of another language. And many languages have bindings for other languages. You can write C code inside of Java. There's something called Swig, which takes C or C++ code and generates bindings for something like 20 or 30 different languages yeah we've talked about this a little bit i don't know if you're set specifically as called binding but we talked about another language is how easy it is to use them inside
所以Prolog有所谓的绑定，你可以创建一个Prolog环境，并在另一种语言中运行Prolog函数。许多语言都有针对其他语言的绑定。你可以在Java中编写C代码。有一个叫Swig的东西，它获取C或C++代码并为大约20或30种不同的语言生成绑定。是的，我们之前讨论过一点，我不知道你是否专门称之为绑定，但我们讨论过另一种语言，即在不同语言中使用它们是多么容易。
of different ones yeah yeah definitely and prolog is definitely easy to use in fact someone has implemented a prolog interpreter in python so you don't even have to use the binding. It's just the interpreters right there. So is Prolog interpreted or compiled? Yes, so Prolog is interpreted. There are different sort of tricks you can use to sort of pre-compute things. And there's this thing called a cut that you can use, which gets into more advanced aspects of Prolog and sort of adds more sort of, I guess, preprocessing.
是的，确实如此，而且Prolog绝对易于使用。事实上，有人用Python实现了一个Prolog解释器，所以你甚至不需要使用绑定。解释器就在那里。那么Prolog是解释型还是编译型？是的，Prolog是解释型的。你可以使用不同的技巧来预计算一些东西。有一个叫“剪枝”（cut）的东西，它涉及Prolog更高级的方面，并增加了一些，我想是更多的预处理。
But yeah, at the heart, it's definitely interpreted language. And if you think about it, the Prolog is, so we talked about MATLAB and how when you're using MATLAB, you might have an operation that says add these two arrays. And it's actually millions of C++ or C, millions of assembly instructions, right? But it's all just one line of MATLAB. Prolog is much the same way, where you're writing these facts, and then you just say one line, like, you know, do I have measles or something. And Prolog is doing all this stuff behind the scenes in C or C++, or as I said, Python has a version.
但总的来说，它绝对是解释型语言。如果你仔细想想，Prolog是……我们谈到了MATLAB，当你使用MATLAB时，你可能有一个操作说“将这两个数组相加”。它实际上是数百万条C++或C指令，数百万条汇编指令，对吧？但它在MATLAB中只是一行代码。Prolog也是一样，你编写这些事实，然后只说一行，比如“我得麻疹了吗？”之类的。而Prolog在后台用C或C++做所有这些事情，或者正如我所说，Python也有一个版本。
So it could be interpreted without really any penalty because there aren't many instructions. So are most of the interpreters commercial or open source? Yeah, so there is GNU Prolog, which is a open source version of prologue there is a swi prologue which is by far the most popular um that one is an open source but uh it's extremely fast the the uh the resolution engine is just insanely fast for that one, highly optimized. I think there are, are there any more that you can think of? There's JIProlog. I believe there's a PyProlog, or maybe it's called PyLog. Let me look it up just so we don't make our third mistake. Oh, it's actually called Pythologic.
所以它可以在没有任何性能损失的情况下被解释，因为指令并不多。那么大多数解释器是商业的还是开源的？是的，有GNU Prolog，这是一个开源的Prolog版本；还有SWI-Prolog，它是目前最流行的。那个是开源的，但它非常快，它的解析引擎速度快得惊人，高度优化。我想，还有其他你能想到的吗？有JIProlog。我相信还有一个PyProlog，或者可能叫PyLog。让我查一下，以免我们犯第三个错误。哦，它实际上叫Pythologic。
But yeah, that's a module for Python that gives you the programming, the Prolog interpreter. So I would imagine that Prolog is used for kind of things like we've already been alluding to, like kind of, or were used for like medical diagnosis things. I know I also saw that they used some for air traffic control stuff, where there's a lot of kind of rules about how something should be handled. Yeah, definitely. I mean, anytime you have a bank of rules. I know that at university we actually developed a prologue theory creator.
但是的，那是Python的一个模块，为你提供了Prolog解释器。所以我猜Prolog被用于我们已经提到的那些事情，比如医疗诊断。我知道我还看到他们用它做空中交通管制，那里有很多关于如何处理某事的规则。是的，绝对。我的意思是，任何时候你有一个规则库。我知道在大学里我们实际上开发了一个Prolog理论创建器。
And so this is really interesting. We input a bunch of theories and observations that were known to be true. And then it automatically just used its deduction engine to come up with new theories so you know I mean this is I'm just making this up but if you know that like all I don't know all graphs you know with this many vertices also have this other property and graphs with this third property have X vertices therefore graphs with this third property have x vertices therefore graphs with this property have that property you know just things like that and it would just it actually came up with just hundreds of new theories and it was really really interesting
这真的很有趣。我们输入了一堆已知为真的理论和观察结果。然后它自动使用其演绎引擎来提出新的理论。所以，我的意思是，我只是编造这个例子，但如果你知道“所有具有这么多顶点的图也具有这种其他属性”，并且“具有这种第三属性的图具有X个顶点”，因此“具有这种第三属性的图具有X个顶点”，因此“具有这种属性的图具有那种属性”。你知道，就像那样，它实际上提出了数百个新理论，这真的非常非常有趣。
and papers were published and things like that and so you feel a little guilty publishing a paper with a theory that you didn't that you wrote a program to create but then on the other hand we published like tons of theories with one paper so we felt like it was justified yeah but yeah it's pretty popular in asia right yeah prologue took off big time in asia it's actually still pretty popular um but other than that it's um you know here in the in the US it's mainly just people use it for geeking out it was used to create Erlang so programming language inventors programming language inventors like Python I mean sorry like Prolog
论文也发表了之类的。所以，发表一篇你通过编写程序创建的理论的论文，你会感到有点内疚，但另一方面，我们用一篇论文发表了大量的理论，所以我们觉得这是合理的。是的，但它在亚洲很受欢迎，对吧？是的，Prolog在亚洲非常火，实际上现在仍然很受欢迎。但除此之外，在美国，它主要是人们用来极客式地钻研。它被用来创建Erlang。所以编程语言发明者，像Python，哦抱歉，像Prolog。
again the key strength of Prolog is that it has this inference engine that does all this deduction and it has this inference engine that does all this deduction. So it has it extremely optimized. So you know one thing you can think of this in terms of numbers. It doesn't have to be facts. So for example let's say navigating a maze.
再次强调，Prolog的关键优势在于它拥有这个进行所有演绎的推理引擎。它拥有这个进行所有演绎的推理引擎。所以它对其进行了极度的优化。所以你可以从数字的角度来考虑这个问题。它不一定非得是事实。例如，假设在迷宫中导航。
You might say you know if you are in this spot of the maze then you're one square away from you know any adjacent spot that you can get to that's not you know blocked by a wall so you can just fill in these rules you can even write another program that generates the rules that looks at the maze and generates all the rules for all the you know adjacent tiles in your maze and then you can just say you know i am in this square is it possible for me to be at the finish line that's actually another thing that we should mention is prologue doesn't just give you yes or no answers but it also will tell you how it gets there so going back to like the measles example you could say do i have avian flu and it says yes but then you can also say well you know
你可能会说，如果你在这个迷宫点，那么你距离任何你可以到达的相邻点只有一格距离，只要它没有被墙挡住。所以你可以填入这些规则，你甚至可以编写另一个程序来生成规则，查看迷宫并为迷宫中所有相邻的瓷砖生成所有规则。然后你就可以说，我在这个方格里，我有可能到达终点线吗？这实际上是我们需要提到的另一件事，Prolog不仅给你“是”或“否”的答案，它还会告诉你它是如何到达那里的。所以回到麻疹的例子，你可以说“我有禽流感吗？”，它说“是”。但然后你也可以说，“那怎么可能？这是我的症状，你是怎么算出来的？”它会说，“哦，我遵循了这条规则，那条规则，还有这条规则，然后我推导出了这个。”所以你可以利用它留下的痕迹来导航迷宫，或者进行机器人控制，以及许多其他任务。是的，我记得有人用Prolog做了一个数独求解器。没错。所以关于如何找出数独谜题中下一个数字的所有规则。是的，我的意思是，数独非常适合这个，对吧？因为你有不同的事实，比如如果我这一行有一个1，那么我在同一行的其他任何地方都没有1。所以这些都只是事实。你可以编写一个元程序，你可以用Python写一个脚本，生成数独的所有事实，或者抱歉，生成数独的所有推论，然后给它事实（即谜题中已经存在的数字），告诉它开始，它会非常快地生成解决方案。这就是我希望人们从中得到的最重要的东西，你可以非常快地编写自己的推理引擎。你可以说，这是我所有的事实，让我遍历所有规则，找出哪些是真的，然后再遍历所有规则。
how is that possible you know here are my symptoms how did i how did you figure it out you'll say oh well i followed this rule and i followed that rule and i followed this rule and then i deduced this so you can use that um you can use that trail that it left behind um to sort of navigate a maze or to do robot control or many other tasks. Yeah, people, I remember doing a, somebody did a Sudoku solver in Prologue that way. Yep. So all the rules about how to figure out the next number in a Sudoku puzzle. Yeah, I mean, Sudoku is perfect for this, right? Because you have different facts like if i have
这怎么可能呢？比如，这是我的症状，你是怎么推断出来的？你会说，哦，我遵循了这条规则，那条规则，还有这条规则，然后我推导出了这个结论。所以你可以利用它留下的轨迹来走出迷宫、控制机器人或完成许多其他任务。是的，我记得有人用 Prolog 写过一个数独求解器，就是用的这种方法。没错，关于如何找出数独谜题中下一个数字的所有规则。是的，数独非常适合这种方法，因为你有不同的事实，比如如果我有
a one in this row then i don't have a one anywhere else in the same row and so these are all just facts you can write a meta program you can write a script in python that just generates all the facts for sudoku and then or sorry generates all the inferences for Sudoku, and then give it the facts, which are the numbers that already exist in the puzzle, and tell it to go, and it will very quickly generate the solution. That's the big thing I want people to get out of this, is you can write your own, you know, inference engine very quickly. You can just say, here's all my facts, let me just go through all the rules, find out which ones are true, and then go through all the rules again.
这一行里有一个数字 1，那么这一行的其他地方就不会再有 1。这些都是事实，你可以编写一个元程序，或者用 Python 写一个脚本，生成数独的所有事实，或者说生成数独的所有推理，然后输入已知事实（即谜题中已有的数字），让它运行，它就能非常快地生成解决方案。这就是我希望大家从中领悟到的核心：你可以非常快速地编写自己的推理引擎。你只需要说，这是我所有的事实，让我遍历所有规则，找出哪些是成立的，然后再遍历一遍所有规则。
You can do that, but it will take a very, very long time. And I don't want to get into the specifics because it gets really complicated, but basically the Prolog guys have made this extremely, extremely fast. And their program, if you write it in Prolog versus make your own, you know, dumb inference engine that just looks at all the rules, it will just run, I don't even know, thousands of times faster. So the inference engine is key. But Prolog does have some weaknesses. Yeah. So this doesn't sound like it would fit, you know, with the way computers work naturally. It doesn't seem like a would fit you know with the way computers work naturally does it seem like a good a good fit I guess you know you I guess you even have here in the notes the von Neumann architecture the way computers are now with you know an
你可以这样做，但这会花费非常非常长的时间。我不想深入细节，因为它变得非常复杂，但基本上Prolog的人们已经让它变得非常非常快。他们的程序，如果你用Prolog编写，而不是自己制作那种只查看所有规则的笨拙推理引擎，它运行速度会快上几千倍。所以推理引擎是关键。但Prolog确实有一些弱点。是的。这听起来不像它能自然地适应计算机的工作方式。它似乎不是一个好的……我想你甚至在笔记里提到了冯·诺依曼架构，现在的计算机有指令线、数据线、寄存器和处理器，试图进行数学指令流。这看起来不像它会工作的方式。
instruction instruction line data lines you know registers and a processor and trying to do you know just streams of math instructions. It doesn't seem exactly how this would work. Yeah, that's so true. I mean, look at, you know, the example we gave where you want to check all these rules. Ideally, what you'd want is to just check all the rules at the same time. Like you don't have to go one rule at a time. You can just say, look, here are all my facts. I want to check every single rule and find out which of these are true. But like, they don't have, I don't have to check them in any order. I just want to check all of them. And then now I have a new set of facts. I want to just check all the rules again. So, you know, think about your brain again. Your brain is
是的，那太对了。我的意思是，看看我们给出的例子，你想检查所有这些规则。理想情况下，你会希望同时检查所有规则。你不必一次检查一条规则。你可以说，看，这是我所有的事实。我想检查每一条规则，找出哪些是真的。但它们没有……我不必按任何顺序检查它们。我只想检查所有规则。然后现在我有一组新的事实。我想再次检查所有规则。所以，想想你的大脑。你的大脑是
completely decentralized. So in other words, you know, all of the neurons in your brain are all acting independently of each other and the fact that you know you only consciously think of one thing at a time or a handful of things at a time is just because those sets of neurons are sort of dominating but in the background in your subconscious you're thinking of just hundreds thousands millions of other things and you're building up millions of inferences, you know, everything you do is adding more to this massive, massive inference engine that you have and everything you see. So this doesn't really fit, right? You know, the way computers work now, they execute one instruction at a time. You know, we talked in the assembly
完全去中心化的。换句话说，你大脑中的所有神经元都在独立运作。你之所以一次只自觉地思考一件事或几件事，只是因为那些神经元集合占据了主导地位。但在后台，在你的潜意识里，你在思考成百上千、数百万的其他事情，你在构建数百万个推论。你所做的一切都在为你拥有的这个庞大的推理引擎增加内容，你所看到的一切也是如此。所以这并不真正适用，对吧？现在的计算机一次执行一条指令。我们在汇编播客中谈到了缓存、寄存器之类的东西。计算机核心一次只能容纳16或32个数字。它只能对其中几个进行操作，而且一次只能执行一条指令。所以这使得Prolog变得非常慢。这违背了Prolog的本质，即你拥有所有这些规则，而顺序并不重要。所以如果你能在人脑上实现Prolog，它可能会运行得快得多。但考虑到计算机现在的样子，这种语言并不真正适合你所处的编程环境。是的，这似乎很难。
podcast about, you know, cache and registers and things like that. And the computer can only hold, at the core, 16, 32 numbers at a time. And it can only operate on several of those and only do one instruction at a time. So this sort of makes Prolog extremely slow. So this goes against the nature of Prolog, which is that you have just all these rules and the order doesn't matter. So if you could implement Prolog on a brain, it would probably run much faster. But given that computers are the way they are, the language doesn't really fit with the environment that you're programming in yeah it seems like it'd be hard
关于缓存、寄存器之类的播客。计算机核心一次只能容纳 16 或 32 个数字，而且一次只能对其中几个进行操作，一次只能执行一条指令。所以这使得 Prolog 的运行速度极慢。这违背了 Prolog 的本质，即你拥有所有规则，且规则顺序无关紧要。因此，如果你能在人脑上实现 Prolog，它可能会运行得快得多。但鉴于计算机目前的运作方式，这种语言与你所处的编程环境并不契合。是的，这听起来确实很难。
like i can't imagine trying to write a gui in prologue oh yeah i mean anything that requires you to do things in sequence sort of just just is going against the nature of the inference engine like the inference engine wants to search and it wants to search everything. And if you want to have a certain recipe, like let's say you want to take a number, you know, add 10, then divide by two and then square it. Well, then you need to create an inference for each of those. You need to say, okay, here's this number
就像我无法想象尝试用Prolog编写GUI。哦，是的，我的意思是任何需要你按顺序做事情的东西，都违背了推理引擎的本质。推理引擎想要搜索，它想要搜索所有东西。如果你想有一个特定的配方，比如你想取一个数字，加10，然后除以2，然后平方。好吧，那么你需要为每一个步骤创建一个推论。你需要说，好的，这是这个数字，
and it's in stage one. And if a number is in stage one, then you add 10 to it. Or if a number is in stage one, then you add 10 to it. Or if a number is in stage one and you add 10 to it, now it's in stage two. But it's going to be looking at the stage three and stage four rules when it implements that one to see if there's anything else that matches. That's not going to be efficient. Yeah, it's going to run extremely slow.
它处于第一阶段。如果一个数字处于第一阶段，那么你就给它加10。或者如果一个数字处于第一阶段，你就给它加10。或者如果一个数字处于第一阶段，你给它加10，现在它处于第二阶段。但当它实现那一步时，它会查看第三阶段和第四阶段的规则，看看是否有其他匹配项。那不会是高效的。是的，它会运行得非常慢。
It just cannot do things in sequence because of its nature. And so, yeah, I mean, a GUI or anything that's time-based or any type of matrix math or anything like that is just going to be just brutally slow and prolonged. Yeah, and I guess that's not really a weakness. That's just not what it's used for. I mean, a weakness yeah yeah we're trying we're stretching a little here maybe to to say what weaknesses are for those but that's okay yeah that's true i guess you know to be more broad the weakness of prologue is just that it
由于其本质，它就是无法按顺序做事。所以，GUI或任何基于时间的东西，或任何类型的矩阵数学之类的东西，在Prolog中都会慢得离谱。是的，我想那并不是真正的弱点。那只是它不被用于那些地方。我的意思是，弱点……是的，我们在这里有点牵强地说明它们的弱点，但这没关系。是的，那是真的。我想更广泛地说，Prolog的弱点只是它
has very specific applications yeah that's right it's very specific purpose yeah that's right and in a way and even in that purpose though it tends to be slower than maybe desirable yeah i would agree with that yeah i mean in in many of the uh expert systems something like prologue is almost overkill you know like the web md how many rules do they really have i mean let's say they have 638 seriously. Seriously? I thought, I was like, man, Patrick's foo is incredibly strong. His Google foo is epic. You know, let's say they have 638,000 rules, right? Now you're starting to approach a space where Prolog is starting to become useful.
有非常具体的应用。是的，没错，它有非常具体的用途。是的，没错。而且即使在那个用途中，它也往往比预期的要慢。是的，我同意这一点。我的意思是，在许多专家系统中，像Prolog这样的东西几乎是杀鸡用牛刀。你知道，比如WebMD，他们到底有多少规则？我的意思是，假设他们有638条。认真的吗？我以为……我当时想，伙计，帕特里克的“功夫”非常强。他的Google搜索能力是史诗级的。你知道，假设他们有638,000条规则，对吧？现在你开始接近Prolog开始变得有用的空间了。
But most systems you can just, you know, implement it in C++. Or, you know, they have different inference engines now in many languages, and so Prolog is, I would say the applications are just too specific. Other than geeking out, or unless you're really concerned about speed and you have just tons of rules, Prolog really has very limited use. But with that said, it is extremely important to learn Prologue. Because just understanding, you know, predicate logic, why it's important. And just, you know, if nothing else, understand, you know, people like the smartest people in the world 30 years ago 40 years ago thought that
但大多数系统你只需要用C++实现它。或者，他们现在在许多语言中都有不同的推理引擎，所以我认为Prolog的应用太具体了。除了极客式钻研，或者除非你真的关心速度并且有海量的规则，否则Prolog的用途非常有限。但话虽如此，学习Prolog仍然非常重要。因为仅仅是理解谓语逻辑，为什么它很重要。而且，如果什么都不做，至少要理解，30年前、40年前世界上最聪明的人认为
prologue would create a human brain and just just let that detonate in your mind for a second you know people minsky and and and all of these guys thought that prologue was going to get human level intelligence and just i think just just accepting that that that was the state of things and just i think just just accepting that that that was a state of things and just knowing that i think is is important yeah well i certainly learned a lot i mean i didn't know a lot of this stuff before and i'm gonna go write up a bunch of rules and ask the prologue what the purpose of the universe is that's right 42 yeah i think i messed that quote up a little didn't i uh no i think you got what's the meaning of life the universe and everything in it yeah that's right that's right we'll get it right 42 okay anyways that was that was geeky uh do you got any wrap-up notes thank you for
Prolog会创造出人脑，让这个想法在你的脑海里爆炸一秒钟。你知道，明斯基和所有这些人认为Prolog会达到人类水平的智能。我只是认为，仅仅接受那是当时的情况，仅仅知道这一点就很重要。是的，我确实学到了很多。我的意思是，我之前不知道很多这些东西，我要去写一堆规则，问Prolog宇宙的目的是什么。没错，42。我想我把那句名言搞砸了一点，对吧？不，我想你得到了，“生命、宇宙以及一切的终极答案是什么？”是的，没错，没错，我们会搞定的，42。好吧，总之，那太极客了。你有什么总结笔记吗？感谢
everybody who's been you know rating us in itunes and reviews, and we've gotten a couple more emails. So thank you for all of those. Continue to do that. If you want to send us an email, programmingthrowdown, one word, at gmail.com. You can check out our website at programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com. I know most people seem to be getting this through iTunes.
每一位在iTunes上给我们评分和评论的人，我们还收到了一些邮件。所以感谢所有这些。请继续这样做。如果你想给我们发邮件，programmingthrowdown（一个词）@gmail.com。你可以查看我们的网站programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com。我知道大多数人似乎是通过iTunes获取这个节目的。
But we do post show notes there, links to the articles we talk about. Not as exhaustive as could be, but you can also write comments about an individual show. Yeah, definitely. I think that, you know, once we get our invites for Google+, we can, we'll have a Google+, you know, we'll put Programming Throwdown on Google+, and you can add it to your circle, and we'll post on upcoming shows and let you know some people didn't know we were out for about
但我们确实在那里发布节目笔记，以及我们谈论的文章链接。虽然不像可能的那样详尽，但你也可以对单个节目发表评论。是的，绝对。我认为，一旦我们收到Google+的邀请，我们就会有Google+，我们会把Programming Throwdown放在Google+上，你可以把它加到你的圈子里，我们会发布即将到来的节目，并让你知道，有些人不知道我们停播了大约
three weeks when we usually do a show bi-weekly because we were both going through moving and being sick and things like that and so the blog sort of keeps people up to date and also is a way for people to sort of tell us sort of what they want to hear so um we got some feedback for different things some people want to talk about games want to talk
三周，而我们通常是双周更新，因为我们都在搬家和生病之类的。所以博客算是让人们了解最新情况，也是人们告诉我们他们想听什么的一种方式。所以我们收到了一些关于不同事物的反馈，有些人想谈论游戏，想谈论
about different platforms and and uh we i think we should kind of we might start doing you know the beginning of the show you know right after the news talk about you know a certain aspect like like games or like frameworks or something like that. So yeah, we might tackle something like that in the future. I think we'll probably think about a little shake-up of the format. Yeah, if you have any suggestions definitely let us know. If you think that
不同的平台。我想我们应该……我们可能会开始在节目开始时，就在新闻之后，谈论某个方面，比如游戏或框架之类的。所以是的，我们将来可能会处理类似的事情。我想我们可能会考虑对格式进行一点调整。是的，如果你有什么建议，一定要告诉我们。如果你认为
we should cut the news a little short and talk about a specific topic that you have interest in or want to know more about. Patrick and i are pretty eclectic when it comes to programming stuff we've done just about everything between the two of us so um we could definitely talk about talk about just about anything so all right well i think that's it yeah all right so next time guys yeah have fun with prologue. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot.
我们应该缩短新闻，谈论你感兴趣或想了解更多的特定主题。帕特里克和我谈到编程时非常博学，我们两人之间几乎做过所有事情，所以我们绝对可以谈论任何事情。好吧，我想就是这样。好的，那么下次见，伙计们。玩得开心，Prolog。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。
Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编，但你必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。